bonjour à tous bienvenue ici sur les
Champs-Élysées et bienvenue dans les
studios du Figaro très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle ce cette
nouvelle édition du 14 juillet on est
ensemble jusqu'à 13h et plus si
affinités et avec nos équipes sur le
terrain à commencer par Timothée
d'Hélène qui est debout depuis l'aube
bonjour Timothée
vous allez monter à bord d'un canon
César et vous allez faire découvrir les
coulisses de
cette pièce majeure d'artillerie aux
internautes du Figaro
absolument Vincent bonjour Vincent
bonjour à tous voilà nous sommes ici sur
le sur l'Arc de Triomphe je vais monter
effectivement dans l'un des deux canons
César de ce 40e régiment d'infanterie de
l'armée de terre et vous les voyez ici
ils sont ici là les César je vous les
montrer à l'image voilà c'est dans un de
ces deux véhicules que je vais monter
dans dans quelques instants vous voyez
également évidemment le l'équipage les
militaires qui sont qui sont là qui sont
présents je peux vous dire que pour eux
la journée a commencé tôt très tôt
puisque le premier briefing a eu lieu ce
matin à 3h15 du matin à la Brétigny à la
base aérienne de Brétigny avec donc ce
premier briefing et puis ensuite départ
de Brétigny à 5h45 qui sont arrivés aux
abords de l'Arc de Triomphe à 6h45 et
puis ensuite et bien vous le voyez ils
se sont mis en place je vais essayer de
vous montrer un petit peu sur ce sur ce
panneau voilà tous les tous les
véhicules qui sont en train et bien de
terminer l'heure leur mise en place vous
avez ici voilà un certain nombre de
véhicules je vais vous montrer également
les véhicules des sapeurs-pompiers
également au loin qui sont qui sont
là-bas les troupes sont en train de
terminer de se mettre en place avant
évidemment le l'inspection générale des
troupes par par les officiers généraux
ça ce sera aux alentours de 9h20 9h30 et
ici évidemment et bien on attend avec
impatience l'arrivée du chef de l'État
le président de la République est
attendu d'ici 10 heures ici au niveau de
l'Arc de Triomphe
merci beaucoup Timothée alors ça c'est à
l'arc de triomphe en bas des
Champs-Élysées il y a Damien Canivet
avec Julien Leclerc bonjour Damien et
mon petit doigt me dit que vous n'êtes
pas seul
votre petit doigt se trompera rarement
Vincent bonjour à toutes et à tous ravi
de vous retrouver ici sur les
Champs-Élysées effectivement je me
trouve pas loin de l'Arc de Triomphe où
je suis avec le lieutenant Axel du
premier régiment de hussard parachutiste
bonjour bonjour merci de nous accorder
un peu de temps je sais qu'il est très
précieux puisque vous allez défiler dans
quelques instants ici sur cette
magnifique artère située en plein centre
de Paris qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de
participer à un tel événement déjà alors
c'est toujours un immense honneur de
participer à ce défiler c'est vraiment
une occasion pour nous de nous
représenter devant la France entière et
voilà surtout à côté de nos hommes etc
de nos hommes de nos chefs c'est
vraiment un honneur et ça reste vraiment
de la mémoire quoi et comment on défile
sur un défilé du 14 juillet vous avez
postulé pour faire partie de cette
parade militaire alors j'ai pas postulé
c'est une chance qui m'a été accordée à
moi et à mon Ploton du coup de
participer à ce défiler et une fois que
nous avons su que nous avons été
désignés par nos chefs
certainement par mérite nous sommes
préparés du coup depuis un mois nous
préparons à fond pour pour réaliser le
défilé le plus magnifique possible et
vous êtes un petit peu stressé ou pas
c'est pas un stress plutôt inexcitation
et voilà on va essayer dans profiter à
fond c'est le mot d'ordre qui m'a donné
à nos hommes d'en profiter et de garder
un maximum d'images en tête et puis
d'être là avant tout pour la France et
pour donner la meilleure image du
régiment possible alors justement votre
régiment c'est le premier régiment de
hussard parachutiste racontez-nous quel
est votre mission le reste de l'année
tout à fait donc le premier régiment du
SERP parachutiste un régiment
d'avant-garde aéroporté c'est un
régiment assez unique parce qu'en fait
c'est le seul régiment blindé de la 11e
régate parachutiste donc ça nous donne
des missions assez particulière et assez
unique donc c'est des missions
principalement de reconnaissance de
renseignements au contact et de combat
en T-shirt donc pour nous pour remplir
ces missions on s'appuie sur nos
capacités très développées dans la
furtivité la mobilité la vitesse et la
puissance de feu et alors pour ça vous
vous appuyez sur un plusieurs véhicules
le véhicule blindé léger et vous avez
aussi ce fameux grizzly qui est assez
singulier on va le regarder il est il
est là-bas on va on va s'en approcher en
quoi est-il si particulier ce véhicule
alors le véhicule grise donc il arrive
le régiment là depuis quelques jours il
va venir donc être en binôme avec le
véhicule blindé léger donc vous venez de
parler et donc pour nous c'est vraiment
une plus-value importante parce que donc
grâce à son autonomie à sa polyvalence
et sa capacité d'emport il va nous
permettre donc de renforcer toutes les
capacités de vous parler donc nos
missions de reconnaissance de
renseignement au contact et de densifier
donc capacité antichard donc voilà c'est
vraiment une manière pour nous de
développer notre capacité au combat
isolé dans la profondeur votre prochaine
mission c'est quoi exactement alors la
prochaine mission je laisse pas encore
précisément mais on espère que ce sera
dans le au début 2024 bien merci
beaucoup lieutenant Axel je tiens quand
même à préciser qu'il y a quelques
instants nous avons assisté à une
cérémonie assez émouvante je dois le
dire l'un de vos frères d'armes a reçu
la Croix de la valeur militaire qui est
une autre distinction lorsque quelqu'un
s'illustre sur le terrain en
l'occurrence était au Mali on a assisté
à ça tout à l'heure et on a assisté à un
autre événement aussi puisque le 14
juillet est aussi l'occasion pour les de
marquer quelque part le coup c'est un
motard de la police nationale qui a
demandé sa chérie en mariage dans un
tout autre registre merci beaucoup
Damien je vois que vous perdez pas le
nord et que on n'est pas on n'est pas
loin du bus TV merci beaucoup Damien et
merci pour pour ce témoignage et de nous
avoir montré justement ces nouveaux
véhicules c'est grizzly on vous retrouve
bien tout au long de la matinée bien sûr
également avec Timothée délène mais on a
également le plaisir de d'avoir Nicolas
Barotte qui n'a pas ménagé ses efforts
cette semaine puisqu'il était au sommet
de l'OTAN à Vénus targe jusque tard hier
soir à l'Hôtel de Brienne où vous avez
suivi
la locution d'Emmanuel Macron on peut
retrouver votre compte rendu dans le
Figaro de ce jour et sur le sur le site
bien entendu bonjour Nicolas Emmanuel
Macron hier a annoncé déjà une a fait
déjà une annonce mais elle ne concerne
pas ce défilé mais le défilé de l'année
prochaine qui ne sera pas là sur les
Champs-Élysées absolument au détour de
son discours donc un traitement à
l'Hôtel de Brienne le 13 juillet le
président aux militaire à la communauté
militaire pour faire passer des messages
il a évoqué donc les 2024 il sera
perturbé par les Jeux Olympiques à Paris
et donc le défilé 14 juillet n'aura pas
lieu sur les Champs-Élysées entre
Vincennes et nations enfin ce qui
s'était fait
effectivement on sait bien que cette
année-là les JO seront si un effort pour
les militaires qui seront
sollicités mis à contribution toute
l'organisation dans la ville sera
perturbée et donc il était en probable
que ce défi ne puisse pas se tenir de
manière habituelle effectivement le
tracé a été modifié on salue Christian
Léon et tous les internautes qui nous
rejoignent actuellement sur le site du
figa bonjour vous commentez avec nous
bien entendu ce défilé vous posez vos
questions Nicolas Barotte est avec mon
plateau c'est le correspondant défense
du Figaro nous aurons également Jules
nos données qui est spécialiste des de
Géopolis et de la géopolitique de la
région de l'Indopacifique et ensuite de
colonel deux officiers supérieurs le
colonel Yann mandreau et le
lieutenant-colonel Vincent les Muller
qui commenteront à se défiler bien sûr
nos envoyer spéciaux sur place bien sûr
sur les commentaires dans les forums on
respecte les chartes de modération
toutes les opinions sont les bienvenues
dans le cadre de l'expression défini par
nos forums et si elles ne sont pas
respectées vous le savez on n'hésitera
pas à bannir vous revenez de Vilnius du
sommet de l'OTAN
la question est portée sur l'adhésion de
l'Ukraine est-ce que après avoir discuté
avec les différents acteurs c'est
toujours difficile parce qu'on est quand
même assez parquet dans les sommets de
l'OTAN mais
est-ce que l'Ukraine peut vraiment
tabler sur une adhésion
c'est ce qu'elle espère parce que quand
on parle de garder de sécurité la seule
vraie garantie c'est l'article 5 du
Traité de l'Atlantique Nord qui prévoit
une assistance mutuelle entre liée pas
forcément militaire mais une assistance
et on voit bien que c'est une garantie
qui est très très forte et c'est ce à
quoi aspire les Ukrainiens pour se
protéger contre la Russie à long terme
alors maintenant il était évident et
même pour le diverses qui ne pourra pas
obtenir une adhésion tout de suite parce
que l'Ukraine est en guerre que le temps
n'a pas l'intention en guerre contre la
Russie et que quoi qu'il en soit il y a
un processus à respecter donc ce que les
Ukrainiens espérer c'était des
engagements assez clair assez fort pour
éviter un retour en arrière pourquoi
parce que on se souvient que des
mauvaises expériences pour les
Ukrainiens
après la du rideau de fer il y a eu ce
mémorable de Budapest avec une
dénucléarisation du pays des garanties
russes n'ont pas été respectées puis en
2008 et au sommet de l'OTAN du Bucarest
l'idée qu'il y avait une perspective
d'adhésion pour l'Ukraine c'était trop
trop peu c'était beaucoup trop pour
Vladimir Poutine qui a considéré que
cette élection le signe d'un futur et la
réforme de l'OTAN mais c'est trop peu
pour protéger l'Ukraine et donc il y a
eu ensuite l'invasion de la Crimée 2014
puis 2022 donc maintenant vous réduire
ski veut des engagements un peu plus
ferme donc c'est ce qui va chercher à
obtenir à travers différentes modalités
techniques et de déclarations qu'il a
plutôt obtenu c'est que tous les
dirigeants ont été de cas publiquement
assez volontaire ça affirmatif on verra
bien à long terme un moyen terme ça se
réalise honnêtement dans
quelques années le sujet va se reposer
pourquoi parce que ce sera toujours une
décision politique et donc le moment
venu les chefs d'État et de gouvernement
décideront si les graines peut adhérer
ou pas l'aide à l'Ukraine on va en
reparler dans un instant j'aimerais bien
qu'on fasse un petit dernier détour
autour de l'Arc de Triomphe retrouver
Timothée délène avant qu'il ne
s'embarque qu'il embarque pardon à bord
d'un de ces canons César Timothée ce
sont les derniers préparatifs et après
vous montez à bord
oui tout à fait Vincent les derniers
préparatifs vous venez peut-être de voir
à l'instant voilà c'est militaire on a
on a bien vérifié que que tous les
véhicules soient évidemment le plus
présentable possible si je puis dire et
voilà ici on se prépare à la à
l'inspection des troupes d'abord par les
généraux et puis ensuite ensuite la
revue des troupes ça ce sera donc une
revue des troupes par Emmanuel Macron
qui sera accompagné évidemment du chef
d'état-major des armées le général tiret
burqa et puis du gouverneur militaire de
de Paris donc ici voilà on sent que ça y
est on commence à à s'approcher de ce
défiler le défilé à proprement parler
qui a été attendu pour pour 10h30 et
vous voyez ici tout est en place je vais
essayer de de m'approcher un petit peu
de cet arc de triomphe pour que vous
voyez bien voilà ici on se prépare à
l'inspection à l'inspection des troupes
vous le voyez et voilà ici les
militaires qui sont en train et bien de
de discuter alors que le ce moment du 14
juillet attends je peux vous dire qu'ici
c'est une grande fierté un deux de
participer à ce défilé du 14 juillet
j'ai pu discuter avec beaucoup d'entre
eux qui m'expliquent que voilà pour une
majorité c'est la première fois qu'ils
vont pouvoir défiler sur les sur les
Champs-Élysées j'entendais l'un des l'un
de ces militaires qui étaient au
téléphone avec son avec son papa voilà
il y a il y a quelques instants et qui
était en train et bien évidemment lui
expliquer à quel moment précis il a allé
arriver et puis voilà comment est-ce
qu'il pourrait le l'apercevoir
éventuellement à la à la caméra dans son
dans son canon César et vous le voyez
ici les troupes sont en place on attend
plus que que l'inspection qui est
attendue d'ici 9h25-9h30
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup Timothée
pendant que vous parliez on a vu arriver
Marlène Schiappa et également le députés
béangère Couillard on est avec Nicolas
Barotte en plateau on parlait donc du
sommet de l'OTAN juste au début de ce
sommet
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé donc la
livraison de missiles scalp à l'Ukraine
est-ce qu'on a une idée du nombre exact
de missiles que la France va livrer dans
tous les cas une estimation on n'a pas
le nom mais on peut dire que c'est
beaucoup pourquoi parce que on a assez
peu de missiles scalpes en stock grosso
modo on en a 400 ce sont des missiles
qui aussi arrivent en fin de vie qui
vont être
rénové à partir de 2030 il y aura des un
futur monsieur de croisière
donc on en a donné un nombre
significatif dit-on à l'Élysée combien
on sait pas objectivement
[Musique]
dizaines j'en sais rien
en tout cas c'est c'est assez peu cela
dit c'est quand même des missiles qui
sont très efficaces pourquoi parce
qu'ils peuvent ils ont très cher donc
votre technologie et ils peuvent percer
les défenses adverses c'est un tirant
profondeur comme on dit et donc ils sont
résistants au brouillage ce qui leur
permet d'atteindre des cibles de haute
valeur c'est pas un métier de contenir
sur les tranchées
pour atteindre un QG un point logistique
très important on a vu comment les
Ukrainiens ont utilisé les Storm Shadow
c'est la même chose que les scalpes il y
a quelques semaines c'est très efficace
c'est dur à intercepter pour les Russes
et donc même si c'est peu le cas c'est
une aide qui sera toujours bienvenue les
Ukrainiens sont quasiment au missiles
près si je puis dire est-ce qu'on peut
faire d'ailleurs un petit point d'étape
sur ce que la France a donné ou à livrer
à l'Ukraine depuis le début de la guerre
alors la France a livré la France est
toujours très discrète sur raison
contrairement à d'autres pays qui
fournissent des délices très détaillées
mais la France a fournie et César ou que
des cartes de l'artillerie sont très
efficaces à longue portée qui sont
mobiles c'est un vrai atout soit
champion de bataille la livraison aussi
des systèmes de défense expérimenté déjà
la première fois en Irak oui après
c'était pas le même contexte qui est pas
le risque de tir de contrepèterie c'est
là l'avantage du César c'est que il peut
tirer et bouger tout de suite donc
éviter d'être la cible un tir de riposte
on a fourni des défenses entières ça me
tait crotale c'est très utile parce
qu'on va bien d'usage des drones et des
bombardements longue distance des Russes
on a fourni du matériel des vagues des
véhicules on a fourni du carburants on a
fourni des munitions donc on est à
contributeur sur le sur le terrain
ensuite la réalité c'est que les stocks
de l'armée française sont quand même
limités et qui a le souci en France au
sein des tata major de conserver quand
même des matériels
ou on fabrique ce matériel ça dépend il
y a des matins qui sont arrivés en fin
de vie comme les
blindés les scabes ou les blindés les
jeux de reconnaissance
AMX 10 RC qui allait être retiré du
service pour être remplacé notamment par
les véhicules Serval qui vont défiler là
au 14 juillet donc c'est ce matériel là
on les livre une façon ils allaient être
modifiés au fur et à mesure les Césars
c'est un matériel dont on a besoin
effectivement une nouvelle commande qui
sont lancées à l'industriel pour les
remplacer ça prend du temps évidemment
la question qui se pose et qui revient
souvent c'est comment on peut se
permettre de fournir ce matériel alors
même que l'État quand l'état actuel on
sait que la France ne pourrait pas mener
une guerre type guerre en Ukraine sur
une longue durée on a parlé de quelques
mois peut-être de 18 mois mais pas
tellement plus oui mais en réalité c'est
une question qui se pose à réellement
donc quelle est la probabilité pour que
la France soit attaqué comme l'Ukraine a
été aucune donc même si on donnait tous
nos Césars Leclerc si jamais on va leur
donner après tout on risque d'attaquer
tout de suite pourquoi c'est parce qu'on
a la dissuasion et la dissuasion
nucléaire nous protège nous protège les
intérêts français contre tout attaque
première chose deuxième chose on a
l'OTAN on a parlé tout à l'heure avec
l'article 5 qui assure une défense
collective donc même si on a peu de
moyens ce qui compte c'est l'addition
des moyens à la France seul mais c'est
la France avec les Allemands les
Britanniques les Américains et ça qui
crée la masse en cas de nécessité il y a
eu plusieurs polémiques sur la loi de
programmation militaire donc qui a été
voté par le Parlement qui représente une
augmentation de de 40% des de l'effort
budgétaire par rapport à la loi
précédente 413 milliards d'euros sur ces
temps
la gauche et la droite
c'est ça qui est intéressant on dénoncer
la lenteur et des effets d'annonces
est-ce que le l'exécutif en a tenu
compte dans la dernière version et
contraire est forcé parce que
là on n'a pas la majorité à l'Assemblée
donc il a forcément composé pour obtenir
un vote du texte alors à l'Assemblée il
a réussi quand même à tenir et et à
écarter des abonnements au Sénat c'était
impossible donc ça n'a à modifier
simbablement le texte pour accélérer
notamment c'est un peu technique on
garde la même volume financier donc 400
milliards de crédits 13 milliards de
recettes extra budgétaires donc même
enveloppe
dans la répartition dans l'accélération
on va un peu plus vite alors ce matin
c'était très intéressant chez nos
confrères de France Info on entendait le
brillant directeur général de l'armement
défendre cette loi de programmation
militaire et dire quand notre confrères
de France Info nous objecter le fait que
ça pouvait être une armée
échantillonnaire disait non c'est une
histoire c'est une affaire de de
cohérence et on a moins de matériel mais
c'est beaucoup plus cohérent avec ce
qu'on a la question qu'il y a c'est
est-ce que cette loi de programmation
militaire au-delà effectivement de
l'augmentation du budget va permettre
d'augmenter nos moyens de monter en
puissance ou simplement d'assurer la
maintenance parce que on renouvelle
notre coûteux arsenal nucléaire et ça ça
coûte cher on assure les salaires bon
c'est sans eux mais le matériel
finalement on l'augmente pas cet LPM
elle montre la réalité de l'armée on a
eu dernières années une volonté
effectivement d'augmenter le nombre de
matériel avec les Griffons les servales
[Musique]
qui remplace des véhicules blindés qui
étaient assez vêtus c'est pour remplacer
les vaves donc de transport de
l'infanterie ou les amis disrc donc on a
parlé donc c'est blindé léger donc il y
a une bonne destination le problème
c'est que on avait commandé ce matériel
mais sans les accompagner des pièces
détachées des munitions de toute la
maintenance qui va avec qui permet aux
unités d'être ensuite déployer et être
efficace sur le terrain aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'il y a un problème
d'urgence en cas de crise comme ça a été
le cas l'année dernière comme ça
pourrait être le cas dans l'avenir il
faudra pouvoir déployer très rapidement
beaucoup de monde et dans ce cas là bon
bah avoir des des beaucoup de véhicules
mais être incapables de les envoyer sur
le terrain parce que il nous manque des
munitions ou des ou des Toure des
mitrailleuses ça ne sert à rien donc le
gouvernement le ministère a préféré
commander moins de matériel mais avoir
de la cohérence et de mots qu'ils
emploie et ça signifie que tout le
soutien et prévu donc c'est prête à
l'emploi donc c'est plus petit mais ça
peut être tout de suite utilisé
les ministres continuent d'arriver
pendant que on probable de cette loi de
programmation militaire Sébastien le
corps du ministre des Armées pas encore
arrivé mais on a vu notamment Olivier
Grégoire Sarah et la Riri et
les d'autres ministres qui François
Braun qui ont échappé et actuellement
c'est un secrétaire d'État aux anciens
combattants
merci beaucoup
l'ancienne secrétaire aux anciens
combattants qui qui était là et
également Sonia baquet
la question autre question c'est la
présence de l'Inde pourquoi la France
donnait tant à mettre l'un à l'honneur
aujourd'hui c'est 25 ans que la France a
un partenariat stratégique avec l'Inde
c'est très important pour la France qui
se veut puissance d'équilibre avec un s
à la fin avec une vision globale avec
une présence aussi dans la région
indopacifique dont on voit bien que ce
sera une région cruciale dans les années
qui viennent avec la question de la
Chine et donc pour équilibrer les
rapports de force avoir un allié aussi
important démographiquement
économiquement que l'Inde c'est
important l'Inde c'est un partenaire
aussi commercial et industriel avec la
vente de matériel des sous-marins
scorpen des avions rafales et donc c'est
un partenaire économique qui est très
important on va en reparler justement
dans un instant avec
mais pour l'instant
nous avons nous allons avoir également
on va nous envoyer spéciaux une question
justement sur ces contrats on parle
d'une vingtaine de rafales l'Inde a
annoncé qu'elle était intéressée par 26
rafales qui sont produits par Dassault
qui est propriétaire du groupe Figaro
36,5 avait déjà été commandé trois
sous-marins scorpen alors les rafales on
voit bien ce que c'est et pas simplement
quand on est
familier les questions de défense mais
les les sous-marins scorpen à quoi elles
peuvent servir pour pour l'Inde ça sert
pas à protéger leur côte à protéger
aussi les les tout le son continent tout
le continent il y a des porte-avions
d'ailleurs et ils ont un deuxième
porte-avion et donc c'est pas qu'ils
vont acquérir des avions parce qu'ils
ont pas encore d'avion pour leur
deuxième porte-avion donc ils ont besoin
de de batailles ils avaient des mics 29
jusqu'à présent et on voit bien qu'il
cherche c'est un peu de distance aussi
avec la Russie même si ça reste un
partenaires pour pour l'Inde et pour ce
qui est des sous-marins il y a une
question effectivement maritime très
importante parce que la Chine développe
donc c'est une nouvelle route de la soie
qui sont des routes commerciales de
Chine jusque en Europe avec des bases
des ports qui sont à qui au fur et à
mesure au Sri Lanka etc à distance ou
pour éviter que les Chinois un moyen à
long terme puisse avoir un contrôle de
cette zone pour garantir la liberté de
navigation c'est important pour les
États riverains d'avoir aussi une
capacité maritime donc c'est le
porte-avions mais aussi des sous-marins
c'est une un élément indispensable
une question peut-être encore le
est-ce que au niveau de des rapports
entre Emmanuel Macron et l'armée les
rapports des débuts de mandat donc il y
a six ans quand Emmanuel Macron était
arrivé son pacifiés ou bien est-ce que
il reste des tensions entre les entre le
entre l'Élysée et Balard là on a un peu
de temps qui s'est écoulé malgré tout ça
dans les esprits hier à Brienne ça
revient dans les conversations dans les
dans les commentaires ironiques les uns
et les autres peuvent faire le président
a eu une petite allusion cet épisode au
début un peu sur le second degré tous
les militaires l'ont relevé on en
parlait et sont demandés si l'un ou
l'autre allait être virée le temps de la
blague du jour du jour au lendemain donc
ça reste marqué c'est plutôt une
question qu'on se posait au gouvernement
ce matin et on a l'impression de voir
des rescapés
globalement les militaires sont plutôt
satisfaits parce que le président a
quand même augmenté considérablement
leur budget la LPM présente un terrain
respecté celle qui a été votée quand
même assez significative tu respirer
plus mais l'armée est bien traitée il y
a aussi un souci et une vraie
interrogation sur les conditions
humaines et sociales au sein de l'armée
avec la fidélisation le recrutement et
le plantamique il y a d'autres
réflexions en cours justement pour pour
mieux prendre en compte les aspirations
des uns et des autres voilà il n'est pas
idéal mais il y a quand même une prise
de conscience au sein du gouvernement et
à l'Élysée qu'il faut entretenir et
faire en sorte que l'armée soit prête
pourquoi parce que il y a
malheureusement une vraie possibilité
éventualité qu'un jour ou l'autre dans
un avenir proche on est besoin peut-être
capacité parce que les prédictions
finalement des chefs d'état-major alors
que justement on voit quelqu'un
d'important pour cette programmation
militaire qui est le ministre du
de l'économie et du budget également
enfin qui est en charge de budget
Bruno Le Maire et
c'est venu semble-t-il en famille
la la toute la question
qui était posé par la chef d'état-major
des armées en tous les cas depuis
l'amiral Guillot donc début des années
2010 finalement est de moins en moins
théorique le retour de ce qu'ils
appelaient les états puissances de voir
un conflit comment les a vu au 19e au
20e siècle et avant même le 19e siècle
demeure aujourd'hui une hypothèse
crédible avec la guerre en Ukraine bien
sûr on voit la multiplication de zone de
tension d'instabilité plus ou moins
forte la guerre en Ukrain effectivement
qui est accapare qui a un vrai danger
une fois sous-estimé mais ailleurs aussi
en Méditerranée on voit bien qu'il y a
des périodes de tension la Turquie qui
est toujours un allié assez compliqué on
va contre Israël et l'Iran il y a un
sujet une possibilité un jour ou l'autre
ou Israël décident de se défendre ou
d'attaquer l'Iran on va bien en Afrique
une instabilité
croissante massive alors même si la
France a un peu retiré on a quand même
des intérêts là-bas des ressortissants
donc on n'est pas indifférent on va bien
de Pacifique donc
c'est peut-être mon objection par
rapport à ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure Nicolas c'est que c'est là où ça
montre quand même d'avoir du matériel
conventionnel du matériel classique
important et en nombre parce que on voit
bien que
Ukraine déjà avait reçu peut-être demain
Iran vers Israël des puissances
nucléaires peuvent se faire la guerre
sans recourir au nucléaire et donc en
recourant au matériel conventionnel la
masse comme ils disent les militaires
c'est très important c'est que on ne
sait pas c'est pas l'option choisie par
l'actuel loi de programmation je suis
d'accord c'est pas le temps choisi mais
c'était une illusion de croire qu'on
pourrait avoir la masse c'est la réalité
c'est que la France et une puissance
moyenne mais elle n'a pas la capacité
d'avoir une armée aussi importante que
celle de de la Russie de la Chine donc
il faut savoir jouer dans sa catégorie
et d'où l'importance dans les discours
du président qui est prise à Paris de
l'importance dans les discours du
président d'insister sur la coalition et
sur l'alliance et donc la place que
France peut jouer dans le temps et
important parce que si on est moteur
dans l'alliance et ben on pourra agréger
des forces et retrouver un peu
d'épaisseur ce qui demande
qu'aujourd'hui et bien effectivement
c'est ce qu'on va voir c'est l'enjeu des
prochaines années et des débats parce
que des débats autour de cette question
et de ses de ses parties pris merci
beaucoup Nicolas dernière toute dernière
question qu'est-ce que vous allez
guetter aujourd'hui là sur le défilé les
réservistes je pense parce qu'il y a des
réservistes qui vont en défiler et c'est
une préoccupation assez importante au
sein du gouvernement du ministère de
faire en sorte de susciter des vocations
d'engagement alors des réservistes il y
a un très beau reportage d'ailleurs que
vous pouvez retrouver sur le site du
Figaro qui a été tourné par Timothée
délai Merci beaucoup Nicolas et
justement on va retrouver Timothée
d'elle qui est sur la qui a obtenu un
sursis et donc qui est encore peut nous
parler également sur la Place de
l'Étoile et à moins que il soit déjà
parti ou il est encore avec nous
Timothée
oui Vincent je suis encore avec vous
j'ai obtenu un sursis comme vous le dit
vous voyez l'Arc de Triomphe qui est ici
qui a une allez peut-être 200 ou 300
mètres de moi en fait je suis avenue
Victor Hugo pour quelle raison et bien
parce que en ce moment même et bien
c'est en tout cas le programme qui
prévoit qu'en ce moment même c'est
l'inspection des troupes et donc voilà
on a dû s'éloigner un petit peu on est
avenue Victor Hugo vous le voyez ici des
militaires et ici des véhicules alors on
pourrait penser on pourrait croire que
ce sont des véhicules qui vont défiler
tout à l'heure parce que comme me
l'expliquer et bien un officier à
l'instant évidemment certains véhicules
ne peuvent pas stationner sur le l'Arc
de Triomphe parce qu'ils sont trop
nombreux et qu'il n'y a pas la place
pour tous les stationner mais il se
trouve qu'ici précisément et bien ce
sont des véhicules en fait de
remplacement vous savez les les
véhicules spare ce sont donc des
véhicules qui n'ont pas vocation à
défiler aujourd'hui mais qui sont là et
bien et au cas où un engin venait à
tomber à tomber en panne il faut dire
que il y a énormément de
de véhicules qui vont qui vont défiler
sur les Champs Elysées aujourd'hui 157
véhicules sont sont prévus et 62 motos
également ça fait ça fait du monde je
leur demandais voilà combien de
véhicules de remplacement sont prévus on
me disait une grosse vingtaine à vue
d'oeil ici vous voyez ils sont seulement
4 mais il y en a d'autres dans les
artères dans les artères dans les autres
artères qui donnent sur cet arc de
triomphe vous le voyez ici c'est un
c'est un va ben un véhicule avant blindé
que vous voyez à l'instant à l'écran
c'est assez imposant et puis voilà
d'autres véhicules un véhicule un petit
véhicule protégé également et puis
derrière tout au bout c'est un porteur
polyvalent logistique comme me
l'expliquait à l'instant c'est ces
militaires qui sont donc heureux d'être
là ils ont participé à toutes les
répétitions mais hélas j'allais dire si
tout se passe bien et bien ils n'auront
pas le plaisir de de défiler sur les
Champs-Élysées tout à l'heure et ils ont
eu en tous les cas l'honneur d'avoir et
ils ont eu l'honneur d'avoir votre
commentaire merci beaucoup Timothée et
on vous suit et on va
retrouver dans un instant également
Damien Canivet mais on accueille en
plateau alors que viennent d'arriver
Franck Riester Clément Beaune Christophe
Béchu Sébastien Lecornu également le
ministre des Armées donc ça veut dire
que le défilé ne va pas tarder à
commencer et que la revue des troupes
par le Président de la République prévu
à 10h
et bien s'approche mais en attendant on
a le plaisir de recevoir Jules Neder
correcteur hors chefs la revue des idées
et chercheurs CNRS spécialiste de l'Inde
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous et de
revenir sur le plateau du Figaro vous
étiez mercredi dans l'émission point de
vue on peut retrouver votre passionnante
interview par un Emmanuel Isaac que vaut
julnodet avant de vous savoir ce que
vaut aujourd'hui l'armée indienne qui en
allons nous voir défiler aujourd'hui il
va y avoir un contingent indien qui qui
va défiler une chose intéressante à
noter là je discutais avec les officiers
qui vont être sur plateau dans un
instant et on relevait effectivement que
c'est la deuxième fois que l'Inde
des fils sur les Champs-Élysées il y
avait eu un précédent en 2009 et c'est
la seule donc c'est le seul État à avoir
son armée qui défile à deux reprises sur
les Champs-Élysées il y a eu un fait
intéressant qui a été relevé qui a
beaucoup circulé dans la presse indienne
enfin sur les médias en ligne c'est que
lors de la répétition il y a quelques
jours sur les Champs-Élysées et de jour
je crois le contingent indien a chanté
en défilant à chanter une chanson dont
les paroles sont s'arrêter s'arrête
Jeanne c'est chat indu Stan Amara donc
qui en gros veut dire à meilleur que le
monde entier enfin notre Inde est
meilleur que le monde entier donc c'est
vous aviez des militaires indiens sur
les Champs-Élysées qui chantaient et
c'est partisans qui se réjouissaient de
ces images
populiste et nationaliste indien que
vaut l'armée indienne aujourd'hui vous
la remet indienne alors je ne suis pas
spécialiste de de
chercheurs mais oui c'est facile mais ce
que je peux vous dire à de très
intéressantes c'est que déjà l'armée
indienne dépend structurellement des
armements russes alors la part de
d'achat enfin de du PIB consacré à
l'achat d'armes russes étant déclin
constance qui montre une tendance à
l'éloignement progressif
de de ce partenariat avec la Russie mais
qui reste un vieux partenariat qui
remontait à l'indépendance de l'Inde
alors selon les travaux on a différentes
estimations mais beaucoup parlent de 80%
de l'Arsenal actuel qui est indien qui
est russe en fait qui s'appuie sur des
technologies russes qui impliquent des
dépendances technologiques des
partenariats le transfert de de
compétences etc donc il y a une
dépendance structurelle une inertie de
ce lien avec la Russie donc la France
pardon l'Inde ne veut pas couper du jour
au lendemain et là
on voit que par contre la part du PIB
est consacré à l'achat d'armement
français tant augmentation constante
donc le lien se renforce et le lien
entre la France et l'Inde et avant tout
un lien sécuritaire et militaire on y
reviendra peut-être un lien sécuritaire
oui justement c'est outre donc on a un
partenariat avec la dans l'armée de
l'air avec les rafales sont produits par
Dacia on rappelle que Dassault est
propriétaire du groupe Figaro
mais est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
partenariats on a vu hier donc l'annonce
au-delà en tous les cas que l'Inde était
intéressé non seulement par 26 nouveaux
rafales en plus des 36 qui avait déjà
été commandé mais également de trois
sous-marins scorpen donc partenariat
avec la marine est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
partenariat militaire avec avec
actuellement
je voulais dire entre la France et
l'Inde il y a des liens qui se
renforcent mais moi je voudrais surtout
insister sur ce lien à diplomatique et
économique qui est d'une nature
complètement
inédite je veux dire la France dans les
échanges commerciaux avec l'Inde la
France est en fait un petit un petit
joueur les Pays-Bas ont plus de volume
d'échanges plus de volume de
d'échanges en euros
avec l'Inde que on en a à la France
l'Allemagne évidemment a encore plus
d'allier économiques encore plus fort
mais la spécificité du lien entre la
France et l'Inde c'est que c'est un lien
avant tout à stratégie sécuritaire et
qui plutôt que de mettre en relation des
entreprises d'un pays avec des
entreprises d'un autre pays un marché
avec un autre là mais en lien
directement deux états et c'est en fait
on le sait les négociations d'armement
c'est avant tout des négociations
même si les industries d'armement sont
impliqués les plans comment la France ce
partenariat sont vus en Inde
[Musique]
le il y a une grande fierté à
pour beaucoup de nationalistes hindous
de ces nouveaux équipements
ces rafales c'est
sous-marins nucléaires à venir parce
qu'on se souvient tous de la tragédie du
sous-marin nucléaire russe à
racheté par l'Inde qui avait sombré
faisant
je n'ai plus le bilan de mort c'était ça
avait secoué la nation donc il y a cette
idée que ça va de pair avec cet élan de
libération enfin de modernisation de
l'Inde et la modernisation du pays passe
évidemment aussi par la synchronisation
de ces armes donc ça rentre dans ce même
ce même fil narratif
qui est arrivé donc
attends quelque chose de particulier de
cette visite
le il est toujours difficile de savoir
quels sont les visées de l'Inde en
termes diplomatique parce que comme le
ministre des Shankar le ministre des
Affaires étrangères indiens le et au
risque lui-même la stratégie de l'Inde
c'est la stratégie du plurilatéralisme
c'est à dire que plutôt
que d'avoir d'être dans un camp bien
défini dossier par dossier on va voir
avec qui on discute et donc on va
changer de râtelier en fonction des
besoins alors la France correspond à
quel dossier dans ce cadre là et alors
nous le lien avec la France il est comme
je le disais c'est sécuritaire
stratégique à deux niveaux en termes
d'armement et des armements les plus
modernes et les plus performants pour
avec des nouveaux rafales donc qui vient
qui vont être achetés par l'Inde qui
iront sur le tout nouveau
porte-avions indiens dont l'Inde est
extrêmement fier
mais il y a aussi en fait donc c'est une
chose à rappeler pour qu'on sache que
c'est que le lien entre la France et
l'Inde donc il y a ce lien sécuritaire
et stratégique qui se développe à partir
des années 70 quand l'Inde fait ses
premiers essais nucléaires que les
États-Unis à se voient d'un mauvais œil
cette nouvelle puissance nucléaire
émergée mais que la France soutient à
l'Inde mais avant ça il y a quand même
quelque chose qui s'appelle la
colonisation et la tentative de la
France de prendre le contrôle du
territoire indien on a une station de
métro à Paris duplex qui porte le nom
donc de du Commandeur général des
comptoirs français en Inde qui
malheureusement là on voit des
militaires des filets mais c'est pas une
des pages les plus glorieuses de notre
Histoire militaire vu que duplex a été
des faits par les Britanniques mais
glorieuses il y a des efforts mais
du coup le fait que la présence
militaire française en Inde c'est pas
quelque chose de nouveau qui a une il y
a une histoire et avec cette histoire
coloniale de la France il y a eu aussi
un déploiement dans tout le Pacifique et
la France est présente dans tout le
Pacifique la Réunion Mayotte
la Nouvelle-Calédonie etc à Tahiti et le
monde aujourd'hui est tourné vers le
Pacifique c'est plus l'Atlantique le
centre du monde et c'est là que tout se
joue et c'est là que la Chine a à monte
en puissance alors on va y revenir dans
un instant c'est passionnant et
justement de savoir aussi également
puisque vous avez parlé de la Chine
est-ce que c'est le seul ennemi de
l'Inde est-ce qu'il y a d'autres ennemis
on va retrouver pour Damien Canivet qui
se trouve non loin des images que l'on
est en train de voir avec vous en
direction de site du Figaro alors que le
président du Sénat deuxième personnage
de l'État est en train d'arriver Gérard
Larcher Damien au niveau sécuritaire
autour de vous comment ça se comment ça
se passe est-ce qu'il y avait un
dispositif particulier ce matin
je peux vous assurer qu'il y a un
dispositif très particulier et
conséquent je vais vous raconter une
petite anecdote Vincent nous étions
effectivement tout à l'heure avenue des
Champs-Élysées plutôt vers la place
Charles de Gaulle où nous avons
interviewé ce lieutenant Excel du
premier régiment de hussard parachutiste
nous avons donc fait la revue des
troupes avant Emmanuel Macron puisque
nous avons remonté cette avenue des
Champs-Élysées pour nous rendre place de
la Concorde nous sommes arrivés à 9h30
et malheureusement nous n'avons pas pu
accéder à la tribune vers laquelle nous
étions prévus et il n'y a aucune
négociation possible c'est dire un peu
le niveau de tension ici normalement il
y a une brigade cynophile qui était
censée mais déminer chaque personne qui
devait rentrer dans cette dans cette
tribune nous sommes arrivés un petit peu
tard et nous avons trouvé voilà ce spot
que vous voyez avec les images de Julien
Leclerc alors sachez que le dispositif
de gendarmerie qui encadre cette avenue
des Champs-Élysées est assez conséquent
nous avons eu l'occasion de discuter
tout à l'heure avec l'un de ses hommes
qui nous expliquait que 10 escadrons de
gendarmerie sont prévus sur les
Champs-Élysées chaque gendarme était
passée d'à peu près 20 mètres de son
Camara pour justement contenir ce public
qui est venu nombreux ici à vue des
Champs-Élysées alors nous avons vu des
passionnés effectivement et bien de
l'armée en tout cas des personnes qui
sont venues assister à ce côté très
glamour de cette parade militaire mais
nous avons vu également et c'est plus
surprenant quoi que pas tant que ça des
spectateurs indiens qui sont venus vous
imaginer le nombre de kilomètres qu'ils
ont parcouru pour assister puisse à
cette cérémonie puisque je vous le
rappelle
240 militaires indiens vont assister
vont défiler ici sur l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées à l'occasion du 25e
anniversaire du partenariat stratégique
entre la France et l'Inde merci beaucoup
Damien alors il y a jugé
jugé de Paris qui nous a rejoint
d'ailleurs vous fait c'est vous fait
vous tires son chapeau il dit il est bon
le reporter il présente son retard comme
une anecdote mais justement le retard il
est dû précisément au dispositif de de
sécurité
voilà le temps est idéal pour défiler
nous également Charles et ce défiler va
durer va débuter maintenant d'ici une
dizaine de minutes avec d'abord la revue
des troupes par Emmanuel Macron alors
que l'on voit justement le véhicule ce
qui doit être le véhicule dans lequel le
commande car dans lequel le président de
la République prendra place avant de
faire de passer ces troupes en revue et
de descendre les Champs-Élysées aux
côtés des autorités militaires après son
accueil par le chef d'état-major des
armes mais le général burqa est le
gouverneur militaire de Paris le général
Christophe Abad qui sont les ennemis de
l'Inde aujourd'hui je ne dis alors on a
mentionné à la Chine évidemment qui fait
des incursions régulières sur le
territoire indien qui grignote petit à
petit la frontière indienne dans
l'Himalaya l'un de le reconnaît pas
explicitement parce que ça impliquerait
des conséquences assez qu'elle n'est pas
prête à assumer l'un n'est pas prête
aujourd'hui un conflit armé avec la
Chine
déjà eu un conflit entre l'un de la et
il y en a eu avec le Pakistan à la
faveur de l'Inde
stabilisation voilà des conflits
territoriaux mais les tensions sont
toujours vives il y a eu des à beaucoup
d'escarnouches à ces derniers temps ça a
beaucoup occupé à la presse indienne
mais l'autre
frontière c'est le Pakistan et là c'est
beaucoup plus tendu on a le cachemire
entre les deux avec une situation qui
est une qui est une région qui est
occupée par l'Inde mais revendiquée par
le Pakistan revendiqué par le Pakistan
qui au moment de l'indépendance le
maharaja du Cachemire qui était hindou a
préféré rejoindre l'Inde plutôt que le
Pakistan mais des accords avaient été
passés le statut de l'état du Cachemire
je vous souhaite une statue particulière
d'une autonomie constitutionnelle
inscrite dans la Constitution que maudit
a évoqué à l'article 270 de la
Constitution que maudit a révoqué on le
rappelle d'ailleurs c'est à ce moment-là
que est revenu d'ailleurs
en tête des menaces la menace d'une
guerre nucléaire puisque chacune des
deux puissances menacée de déclencher le
feu nucléaire alors la plus grande
tension historiquement c'était en 2002
il y avait eu des maudits étaient à ce
moment-là Chief Minister du Gujarat où
il avait été à la tête donc d'un état et
accusé d'avoir participé à
l'organisation de pogrom anti-musulmans
suite à quoi il avait été interdit de
visa afin d'entrer sur le territoire
britannique et américain
interdiction qui a été révoquée quand on
s'est aperçut qu'il allait ne pouvoir
quelles sont les rapports justement
militaires et avec la Grande-Bretagne
qui est l'ancienne puissance coloniale
ils sont beaucoup beaucoup plus faibles
et finalement à les la France
n'étant pas la dernière puissance
colonisatrice en date bénéficient de
cette faveur peut-être de l'oubli mais
il n'aurait pas été possible après avoir
lutté pour l'indépendance de rétablir
des liens militaires trop trop même si
l'influence britannique ce sont dans le
l'organisation de la présence dans la
culture et dans la culture dans la
culture de l'élite notamment et maudit
travail à
toutes les traces
mais c'est ça passe par un travail de
réécriture d'emmanuels scolaires de de
desquels on essaye d'écarter des figures
comme ça de javelle Nero par exemple le
Premier ministre de l'Inde et donc il y
a un travail d'amnésie collectif qui est
en train d'être fait et les jeunes
Indiens
quelles sont les rapports avec les
États-Unis les rapports avec les
États-Unis ont toujours été un peu à
compliquer parce que les États-Unis
avaient aussi des liens très forts avec
le Pakistan et donc les États-Unis
jouaient peut-être un un jeu trouble
mais là avec la menace chinoise se
faisant plus pressante les liens se
resserre on a vu la visite de maudit à
bayden récemment de nombreux contrats
également signés donc avec toujours
cette angoisse
des contrats militaires
un petit doute tu veux pas dire de
bêtises il y en a eu il y en a il y en
aura encore sur la dernière visite je
j'avoue avoir un petit doute là on
vérifiera
vous l'avez rappelé sur sur ce plateau
les liens avec les récits sont et vous
l'avez répété tout à l'heure les liens
avec la Russie sont encore très forts
mais ils sont en train de de diminuer en
tous les cas la part du PIB vous disiez
consacrer aux armements russes étaient
en train de diminuer est-ce que les
déboires de de l'armée russe en
Ukraine ou en tous les cas la situation
actuelle
n'incite pas les les Indiens à
en tous les cas être moins moins
confiant envers leur ancien partenaire
russe
certainement comme tous les partenaires
de la Russie aujourd'hui une certaine
inquiétude sur l'avenir de leur
partenaire et il y a un degré
d'incertitude qui est énorme mais
la l'Inde n'a pas coupé les ponts avec
la Russie l'Inde qui est si attachée à
la question de l'intégrité territoire
territoriale que ce soit dans sa
relation enfin dans sa frontière avec le
avec la Chine ou avec le Pakistan là a
décidé de ne pas voter la résolution à
poser de l'ONU à contre l'entrée en
guerre ils sont plutôt alignés chinois
sur cette question là c'est toujours
cette idée de d'une Inde en retrait qui
joue la carte du plurilatéralisme qui ne
choisit pas de Caen qui construit d'une
manière sur un mode différent de la
France une certaine autonomie
stratégique alors autonomie stratégique
mais est-ce que il y a une compétition
pour le leadership justement de cette
zone ind scientifique avec notamment la
Chine au nord et puis l'Australie au sud
alors il y a une question en fait qu'on
se pose pas assez c'est si un conflit
éclatait avec la Chine notamment entre
les États-Unis et la Chine est-ce que
l'Inde rejoindra le conflit sachant
qu'elle pourrait se faire à déborder
très vite par les Chinois qui sont
massés assez frontières et qui
pourraient être un autre front apprendre
diversion peut-être mais
ça serait une question
que les États-Unis se posent ils en
doutent très fort nous on se pose pas
ces questions ces questions sont pas
discutées par la représentation
nationale elles sont pas discutées au
Parlement c'est des discussions qui
relèvent de l'exécutif imaginez
rappelez-vous ces sous-marins qu'on
voulait vendre ses frégates qu'on
voulait vendre à Poutine ça nous allie
et qui nous ont empêché de les vendre
et si aujourd'hui l'Ukraine Poutine
avait ces deux frégates
changer des choses c'est frégate aurait
été Mobil pour l'Ukraine à qui on donne
des Arges est-ce qu'on veut armer là
on rappellera que n'ont pas été vendus à
la Russie en échange de d'ailleurs de
vendre d'hélicoptère d'Airbus et le
critères à la Pologne qui finalement a
acheté des hélicoptères américains après
mais toute la question de des armements
et le régime de maudit étant un régime
autoritaire dont certains dénoncent le
potentiel génocidaire
pourquoi mais l'Inde moi c'est la
question je poserai pour terminer c'est
ce que j'ai une dernière question à vous
poser qu'allez-vous guetter aujourd'hui
je vais je vais regarder le les
tentatives de mise en scène personnelle
de maudit et de de tout le travail de
polissage de son charisme et de son
image je suis assez curieux de voir pour
observer ça 17h05 également prise de
parole de d'Emmanuel Macron et de Nara
ça me dit à l'issue du déjeuner qui
doivent avoir après ce défilé bien sûr
cette prise de parole vous pourrez la
suivre en direct sur le site du Figaro
merci beaucoup Jules je signale que vous
êtes un spécialiste de l'Inde et en
particulier vous êtes sociologue de
formation et donc la spécialiste
notamment de la caste et du système de
casque indienne et c'est l'objet de
votre prochain livre qui paraîtra aux
éditions Oxford University presse et
donc on lira ça avec avec intérêt et ce
qui sera bien pour pour l'esprit parce
qu'on apprendra des choses et en plus on
pourra améliorer notre anglais merci
tout ça avec vous merci bonne journée à
vous merci vous restez avec nous à
l'instant le temps que on retourne sur
les Champs-Élysées alors que l'on voit
Brigitte Macron
arrivé à la tribune présidentielle avec
la première ministre Elisabeth borne ce
qui semble être de dos Olivier du soft
et Sébastien
Lecornu on a vu également tout à l'heure
Christian Combon le président le
président de
la Commission de force armée et
étrangère et de et diplomatique au Sénat
Timo alors est-ce que Damien Canivez est
avec nous apparemment ça se prépare le
défilé autour de la tribune
présidentielle Damien
oui exactement ça se prépare on sent que
ça s'active en tout cas disons que
chacun prend ses places nous sommes
juste à l'angle entre la Place de la
Concorde et l'avenue des Champs-Élysées
alors nous sommes autour nous sommes
dans le public voilà il y a des jeunes
du service national universel qui
décideront pas aujourd'hui parce que
vous imaginez bien que les places sont
chers nous voyons également des généraux
des représentants militaires qui sont
installés en tribune des invités en
toutes les personnes que vous voyez à
l'image de Julien Leclerc sont des
personnes qui ont été invitées qui ont
reçu un précieux carton du Palais de
l'Élysée ça s'active puisqu'il est 10h
et le président de la République est
peut-être arrivé déjà où il est sur le
point d'arriver à vue de Friedland et il
sera accueilli par le général d'armée
Thierry burkin qui est le chef
d'état-major des armées ensuite il sera
également accueilli par le gouverneur
militaire de Paris le général de corps
d'armée Christophe Abad et ensuite il y
aura donc cette revue des troupes cette
remontée des Champs-Élysées direction
place de la discord ou les honneurs lui
seront rendus par les premiers et
deuxième régiment d'infanterie c'est
toujours un moment assez assez solennel
on a eu l'occasion d'assister aux
répétitions du 14 juillet avec une
doublure d'Emmanuel Macron parce que oui
il existe une doublure d'Emmanuel Macron
pour les répétitions du 14 juillet et
vous allez voir que que ce moment et cet
animation initiale avec cette musique
militaire internationale est absolument
bluffante justement on va suivre ça avec
le colonel Vincent les Muller qui vient
de nous rejoindre merci beaucoup Damien
alors que on voit les derniers dernières
personnalité
autour de la première ministre Elisabeth
borne et qu'on remonte l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées ou nous recevons donc les
images de l'AFPC c'est l'AFP qui qui
envoie ses images donc parfois on peut
avoir des des images qui qui passent
d'un plan à l'autre ne vous inquiétez
pas on a les meilleures spécialistes
pour commenter cet événement on est avec
donc le colonel lieutenant-colonel
Vincent lumière il sera bientôt colonel
et qui est officier à l'état-major de
l'armée de terre bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être à tout à l'heure d'être avec nous
on
question le thème de de cette
de ce défilé chaque année il y en a un
cette année c'est sur les forces morales
qu'est-ce qu'on entend par là alors les
forces morales effectivement le thème de
cette année nos forces morales donc le
choix qui a été fait c'est de présenter
donc vous le verrez tout au long de ce
défiler tout au long de la journée les
forces morales françaises donc c'est
juste un échantillon puisque les armées
sont bien l'émanation de la nation donc
nous verrons un échantillon est-ce que
nous allons voir on va commencer par des
jeunes des jeunes qui sont dans les
lycées militaires dans les écoles de
formation on verra ensuite tous ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui dans l'armée évite
d'active en activité et derrière
également des réservistes et on finira
par un tableau mémoriel en hommage à la
fois à nos anciens à la fois nos blessés
et ceux qui sont morts en opération et
vous pourrez bien sûr donner suivre
cette cet événement vous pouvez bien sûr
suivre ce défilé avec nous que vous
commentez vous posez vos questions vous
savez les meilleurs spécialistes le
colonel dans colonne le Muller qui est à
l'état-major de l'armée de terre donc
qui connaît en plus tous les programmes
d'armement et également le colonel Yann
Monroe qui prendra son relais dans trois
quarts d'heure et qui lui est
complètement affûté sur les questions de
recrutement et de réserves justement et
de cette réserve opérationnelle alors
que on voit arriver le sans doute le
Premier ministre indien narenda maudit
donc accueilli par Elizabeth borne pas
par Emmanuel Macron parce que justement
Emmanuel Macron lui se trouve tout près
de là où se trouve Timothée délai
autour de l'Arc de Triomphe avant le
passage en revue alors avant d'avoir
justement cette séquence de cette
séquence
je voudrais avoir le l'autre thématique
que l'on va pouvoir
que l'on va vivre en tous les cas et qui
est à l'honneur lors de ce défilé c'est
la présence justement de du Premier
ministre indien comment ça va se
s'illustrer ce manifester cette cette
présence indienne sur le sur le sur le
défilé donc là l'un des fait
effectivement le le l'invité d'honneur
on le verra aussi il y a d'autres
partenaires étrangers qui seront
présents africains européens et otaniens
et donc là aujourd'hui on célèbre les 25
ans de partenariat stratégiques avec
avec l'Inde ils sont ici aussi pour
réfléchir renouveler quel partenariat on
peut avoir
et donc on verra défiler à la fois dans
les airs et sur terre des des
contingents indiens en particulier sur
Terre on l'a dit tout à l'heure 240
personnes soldats indiens des trois
armées terre Hermer et on verra
également des rafales indiens qui seront
dans les airs
c'est ça
Emmanuel Macron qui vient d'arriver donc
vient d'être accueilli par le général
Thierry Burckard chef d'état-major des
armées et avec qui sont en train de
discuter auparavant par le général
Christophe Abad gouverneur militaire de
Paris c'est quoi le d'ailleurs le rôle
d'un gouverneur militaire économique la
France est divisée en région en zone de
défense et dans chaque zone de défense
il y a un gouverneur militaire est
chargé de répondre à la sécurité et
d'être l'interlocuteur des préfets de
zone
donc le gouverneur militaire de Paris
c'est donc le général à battre comme
vous l'avez dit qui est chargé lui de la
zone de défense de Paris et notamment
pour toute l'opération sentinelle
parisienne c'est lui qui est en première
ligne et donc le colonel burqar
légionnaire de formation officiers de
légion
de formation qui donc
a pris place également à bord du
commande car
du président de la République
et donc on va laisser vivre ces
premières images de la revue des troupes
par
saint-cyrien il a fait aussi le lycée
militaire d'Aix-en-Provence qu'on verra
défiler donc c'est pour vous montrer un
petit peu les parcours qu'on peut avoir
donc en commençant très jeune mais
jusque les plus hautes fonctions dans la
défense
et qui est passé d'ailleurs par
une fonction que connaissent tous les
journalistes qui est celle de
porte-parole de l'état-major
écoute les questions de défense
connaissent bien l'actuel chef
d'état-major des armées et bien tout
près de là où se trouve Emmanuel Macron
il y a Timothée d'Hélène
vous est-ce que vous avez vu passer ou
est-ce que vous voyez passer le
président
alors on se tient prêt effectivement et
là c'est la garde
la Garde Républicaine alors qu'il y a
une intervention à l'instant même où je
prends la parole de la part des
gendarmes vous l'avez peut-être vu sur
ces sur ces images c'est vrai que on va
peut-être pas très bien mais c'était un
petit moment de stress là ils sont mis à
courir d'un coup voilà c'est simplement
un individu qui est ici de s'approcher
évidemment c'est pas le bon moment parce
que vous le voyez à l'instant voilà
c'est un peu blanc mais c'est maintenant
voilà le chef de l'État qui était en
train de passer à quelques centaines de
mètres de nous vous le voyez le voici à
l'instant sur son commande car il est en
train et bien de passer les troupes en
revue accompagné vous l'avez dit du chef
d'état-major des armées et puis derrière
c'est le commande card du gouverneur
militaire de Paris le voici le chef de
l'État avec son son cortège voilà le
cortège donc présidentiel et puis la
Garde Républicaine évidemment et qui est
qui est là et puis les je le disais les
les c'est la gendarmerie mobile qui qui
veillent à la sécurité et qui qui sont
peut-être un peu tendus faut dire que le
moment et le moment est important
mais mais voilà pour le moment en tout
cas tout se passe bien on vous rassure
et donc le président de la République
qui vient de de passer pour cette revue
des troupes que l'on va maintenant
rejoindre dans dans quelques instants
pour monter à bord de ce qu'annoncésar
et cette merci Timothée cette séquence
sera à suivre avec
le collège les Muller qui commentera la
partie justement
montée du défilé alors on a vu donc
Emmanuel Macron
commence à descente et sa revue des
troupes de Champs-Élysées alors que le
Premier ministre indien invité de cette
nouvelle édition du 14 juillet
s'entretient avec
l'épouse du chef de l'État qu'est-ce que
le président passe en revue très
exactement comme la lumière donc là il
va passer en revue l'ensemble des
troupes qui vont défiler donc il
commence par ceux qui sont au niveau de
l'étoile donc les troupes motorisées là
derrière on voit les chars Leclerc et
ensuite il passera devant les troupes
les troupes à pied
au fond là en fond de tableau juste
après les les bérets rouges qui eux sont
sur le dernier véhicule le serval de le
dernier véhicule de la gamme scorpion
qu'on vient de recevoir d'ailleurs le
serval c'est la première fois qui défile
aussi sur ce sur le défilé on a d'autres
véhicules appelé grizzly ils sont un
petit peu le les véhicules nouvelle
génération par rapport aux commandes car
sur lesquels sont le président de la
République et le chef d'état-major des
armées
c'est c'est véhicules vous avez
d'ailleurs contribué enfin dans tous les
cas vous avez travaillé sur ces
questions là puisque vous travaillez sur
ces questions d'équipement avec la
majeure de l'armée de terre qu'est-ce
qui permette de de faire et qu'est-ce
qu'ils apportent en plus à nos armées
alors c'est c'est un des objectifs aussi
de ce de ce défiler là on a évoqué l'axe
international il y a aussi l'axe
modernisation montrer que en modernise à
la fois nos équipements et à la fois
donc nos esprits pour faire face aux
enjeux de demain et donc dans ce défi là
on va voir beaucoup de véhicules aussi
bien donc sur terre que des engins en
l'air qui sont de nouvelles générations
et qui vont montrer ce que sera l'armée
française de demain le pour les
véhicules de l'armée de terre dont on a
parlé on a donc l'ensemble de la gamme
scorpion actuellement délivré donc avec
du jaguar qui va défiler du serval
le le char Leclerc qui n'est pas dans la
gamme scorpion mais qui qui va qui va
petit à petit s'en rapprocher qui va
être rénové donc on est sur des
véhicules modernes et qui seront
délivrés petit à petit au cours de la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
et justement l'autre programmation
militaire qui a été
hier par le Parlement ces derniers jours
par le Parlement et qui prévoit donc une
augmentation des crédits militaires et
également donc la fourniture de nouveaux
matériels mais également un
renouvellement de l'arsenal nucléaire
c'est bien ça oui donc il y a des
efforts qui vont être portés sur la
dissuasion nucléaire de façon
évidente puisque c'est c'est notre notre
bouclier principal face à toute à toute
menace et donc il faut qu'on anticipe
ces différentes on va dire les
obsolescences qu'on pourrait avoir dans
le domaine et mais en complète ça cette
dissuasion là par une des armées
conventionnelles avec des outils
conventionnels qui seront solides
robustes puissants et qui auront cette
capacité à justement de à être connecté
ensemble pour pouvoir
accélérer le champ de bataille accélérer
les combats de demain
on va rejoindre dans un instant Damien
Canivez qui se trouve lui en bas des des
Champs-Élysées alors que on voit le
Premier ministre indien en grande
conversation avant l'arrivée du
président de la République
par la prochaine séquence que l'on va
voir ou en tous les cas qui va se
produire pour le président de la
République ce sera l'arrivée du dans
deux minutes maintenant en tout cas si
on se réfère au programme officiels qui
sont les honneurs rendus par place de la
Concorde par les premiers et deuxième
régiment d'infanterie de la gare
républicaine
cette garde c'est pas simplement une
garde d'apparaté elle a elle a une
réelle fonction de de militaire
et et également de protection du
des de la bêtement de la République
effectivement c'est sa mission
principale donc on la voit régulièrement
mise à l'honneur lors de du 14 juillet
ou d'événements républicains importants
mais ça fonction principale c'est bien
de protéger l'ensemble des sites de la
République
et donc on peut les voir très
régulièrement mais soit devant
l'Assemblée soit sur devant Matignon ou
encore à l'Élysée
Emmanuel Macron donc qui est en train de
descendre alors que on voit la
première ministre et Sarah el raheri
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre des
armées qui chargée des anciens
combattants et de la mémoire
et on voit également donc les personnes
qui affluent devant le cortège
présidentielle en tous les cas pour
prendre
les photos du cortège présidentiel c'est
d'ailleurs c'est un signe des temps
maintenant on a plus les images directes
on les a à travers les smartphones qui
prennent et qui prennent les images
c'est on voit également et par ailleurs
on voit que le chef d'État est toujours
en train de descendre de des
Champs-Élysées
on va savoir d'ailleurs si l'ambiance
est un petit peu plus calme que les
années précédentes parce que ça c'est
toujours un test un test politique pour
pour le président de la République
qui a été un certain nombre de fois soit
applaudi soit sifflé est-ce que Damien
Canivet est avec nous ou bien est-ce que
il y a les brouillages qui opère et on
ne peut plus s'entendre
non je vous entends très bien moi
Vincent roux nous sommes effectivement à
proximité de la tribune présidentielle
où vous avez effectivement constaté
l'arrivée dans certains nombres de
personnalités politiques avec le Premier
ministre indien naren damodi Emmanuel
Macron effectivement devra arriver un
récemment sous peu sous nos yeux
puisqu'il est actuellement avenue des
Champs-Élysées alors la revue des
troupes se passe dans un dans un ordre
très particulier il y a d'abord la revue
des troupes motorisés qui se trouve à
proximité de la place Charles de Gaulle
puis vient ensuite la revue des
trompettes pieds ensuite il y a la
Légion étrangère vous savez cette légion
et les pionniers reconnaissable à leur
tablier de de sa peur la barbe ainsi que
que lâche et on va voir Emmanuel Macron
effectivement à bord de son de son
véhicule de reconnaissance son véhicule
léger de reconnaissance avec le
gouverneur de militaire de Paris
notamment c'est vrai qu'ici l'ambiance
est calme pour l'instant mais on Piaf un
petit peu d'impatience parce que toutes
les personnes que vous voyez à l'image
sont arrivées ici très tôt il y a eu
aussi un le parcours du combattant
forcément pour accéder à cette tribune
puisqu'il y a eu beaucoup de de fouilles
en amont pour accéder sur cette sur
cette tribune alors vous voyez que le
dispositif est est organisé de telle
manière que les tribunes sont en retrait
vous avez des barrières et le service
d'ordre de l'Élysée qui est
effectivement au bord de l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées avec les gendarmes
mobiles qui forment un deuxième rempart
de façon à sécuriser au maximum ce
défiler militaire qui devrait commencer
dans les toutes prochaines minutes
alors que l'on voit descendre le cortège
présidentiel
qui est encore au milieu des
Champs-Élysées
merci beaucoup Damien on va revenir vers
vous et surtout on va garder vos images
dès que l'AFP changera de plan parce que
c'est quand même on préfère avoir les
images des Champs-Élysées même si l'an
prochain ça ne sera pas là qu'il y aura
le défilé que d'avoir les plans de coupe
même si c'est avec les membres du
gouvernement
et qui doivent en tous les cas
accueillir tout à l'heure le président
de la République je vous ai vu tout à
l'heure
arborer un insigne que j'ai vu
d'ailleurs que chaque bande du
gouvernement en tout cas certains
membres du gouvernement accroché quand
ils sont arrivés c'est le bleuet il est
à l'honneur cette année c'est ça Vincent
donc je sais pas si là il est visible à
la caméra donc en tout cas je l'ai je
l'ai un petit peu plus bas sur moi et
tout tous ceux participent aujourd'hui
au défilé et d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit
aussi même dans les dans les tribunes
porte le bleu et de France
d'ici deux ans ça sera les 100 ans de
cette œuvre caritative et donc c'est une
œuvre une initiative de deux infirmières
de l'Institut sur nationale des
Invalides qui pour soutenir les blessés
de guerre avec confectionné donc des
bleus et pourquoi le bleuet parce que
c'est avec le coquelicot qui est plutôt
utilisé en Grande-Bretagne le bleuet et
la seule fleur qui repousse sur les
champs de bataille donc c'est vraiment
un signe fort de de soutien pour nos
blessés et pour leur famille et ils sont
à l'honneur également cette année mais
chaque année ils sont à l'honneur et
cette année on continue de l'écoémorer
évidemment avec vous le verrez en fond
de tableau
les 80 ans les médailles de la de la
résistance et toute une jeunesse qui est
là pour faire le lien intergénérationnel
entre ce qui s'est passé avant l'avenir
qui que les enjeux qu'on pourrait avoir
donc
et le bleuet à toute sa place dans ce
système il y a toujours effectivement un
hommage aux blessés enfin dans tous les
cas un hommage informel aux blessés qui
est rendu
après le après les défilés notamment
quand le président de la République ou
la première ministre vont les voir ce
qu'on a vu en tous les cas lors de
précédentes édition du 14 juillet on a
une question de Jerem qui nous dit qui
nous demande est-ce que la dissuasion
nucléaire ne coûte pas trop cher alors
vous avez pas pouvoir exprimer un
jugement de valeur bien évidemment par
rapport à ça mais est-ce que on a une
idée en tous les cas de ce que
représente cette cette dissuasion
nucléaire dans dans le budget je vous
demande pas un chiffre précis mais en
tous les cas en termes de on a malgré
tout on a une estimation à pouvoir
donner aujourd'hui ce qu'on ce qu'on dit
et donc c'est c'est quand même appuyé
sur sur les faits c'est que ça coûterait
7 euros par mois par français donc
aujourd'hui c'est n'importe quel
abonnement euh coûte à peu près ce prix
là pour pour voir des séries télévisées
etc je pense que pour 7 euros avoir
l'assurance nucléaire et
que les feux téléphone mais c'est moins
cher que sur Netflix donc je suis en
train de me dire donc ça vaut le coup
d'accord mais dans l'ensemble du budget
en tous les cas de du budget des armées
ça quand même c'est c'est une place
importante ça a une place importante
mais qui est qui qui s'entend et qui est
qui est tout à fait logique aujourd'hui
si la France
à sa place justement dans dans
l'écosystème international c'est
notamment grâce à cette situation
nucléaire ça je l'entends mais c'est une
question en fait qui est souvent posée
par rapport parce que c'est une question
qui était soulevé tout à l'heure on en
parlait avec Nicolas Barotte on a
tendance souvent à parier sur la
dissuasion nucléaire en se disant que
c'était est-ce que il y a pas un risque
soit un peu une espèce de Ligne Maginot
et qui nous dispense justement de c'est
en tout cas le général des portes qui
pose souvent cette question là de faire
les de faire l'effort nécessaire sur les
armements plus classiques plus
conventionnelles
très sincèrement de c'est un choix
politique donc
il revient effectivement non mais de
décider où est-ce qu'on met les efforts
c'est c'est à l'Assemblée nationale et
au gouvernement de décider comment
est-ce qu'on doit employer cette notre
ressource financière moi ce que
j'observe et c'est un peu ce que j'ai
dit aussi en introduction c'est qu'on a
quand même un équilibre qui est donné
entre des la dissuasion nucléaires et
d'autres investissements qui seront fait
à la fois pour les forces
conventionnelles on va le voir dans le
défilé avec tous les nouveaux matériels
ce colonel maîtrise bien son sujet nos
Guy Charles et ben oui vous avez raison
d'être avec nous vous êtes à raison
d'être en direct sur le site du Figaro
c'est là où on a les meilleures
spécialistes les meilleures connaisseurs
les meilleurs reporters également sur le
terrain avec les images je vous le voyez
en direct du défilé la garde
républicaine qui est en train d'arriver
sur la place de la Concorde avant
qui précède le président de la
République 21 on est un petit peu en
retard par rapport au programme initial
qui prévoyait déjà une arrivée un petit
peu plus tôt du chef de l'État mais on
va continuer à suivre ça avec vous
ensemble et vous continuez à poser vos
questions c'est pouvoir justement on est
là pour pouvoir y répondre en marge et
en parallèle de ces images en direct des
Champs-Élysées qu'on va laisser vivre
avec l'arrivée du président de la
République à la tribune présidentielle
[Musique]
la secrétaire d'états chargées des
anciens combattants et de la mémoire et
ce n'est pas Sarah el haïri qu'on a vu
juste avant qui elle et secrétaire
d'État mais
auprès de du ministre de l'éducation
nationale pas pendiale et elle est
chargée de la jeunesse et du service
national universel qui est un dispositif
qui est en justement mis en place
un peu laborieusement il faut quand même
le dire je pense que le discours hier du
président de la République a réafficher
sa volonté de de relancer ce dispositif
là on le voit donc monsieur le Président
de la République saluait le chef
d'état-major de l'armée de terre général
chill général Shield
saint-cyrien de la promotion lieutenant
Tom Morel
salut chef d'état-major de la Marine
nationale l'amiral vendiez
[Musique]
chef d'état-major de l'armée de l'air et
de l'espace
et le directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale dans quelques
instants
[Musique]
donc il est accompagné derrière aussi
par le chef d'état-major particulier qui
est avec lui un général
aérien avec lui à la à la voilà Mendon à
la présidence de la République
[Musique]
qui va maintenant rendre les honneurs
donc au drapeau ce qu'on peut voir et
c'est le un des seuls moments où on le
fait le on met le drapeau à
l'horizontale en dehors de son fourreau
c'est pour rendre les hommages au
président de la République
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un moment particulièrement
solennel
pour
lorsque moi j'ai défilé pour la première
fois sur les Champs-Élysées on avait ce
contraste aussi entre le moment
solennelle du début du défilé qui est
absolument calme et ensuite le début
l'ouverture par la patrouille de France
qui après lance les applaudissements de
toute la population française c'est
vraiment un moment extraordinaire
répondre à une question de pose chaque
année à quoi correspond justement cette
musique
[Musique]
bon alors on va se demander au
colonelandro de pouvoir répondre quand
il prendra votre
temps chacun ça c'est Roland on l'entend
souvent en plus sur des trucs d'armes
c'est la marge de Marengo de mémoire
mais je marigot
repose la question aux internautes il y
a d'autres questions qui sont posées par
les internautes notamment
le une question par Charles qui
je vous demande pourquoi
l'avion a mis longtemps à s'imposer sur
le plan international sur le Rafale
c'est une question en tous les cas qu'on
va pouvoir essayer d'aborder on va
essayer de retrouver Timothée délaime
qui lui se trouve alors qu'on va rester
sur ces images au
haut de l'Arc de Triomphe avant de
monter à bord du César vous êtes
justement avec un militaire Timothée
absolument Vincent je suis avec le
maréchal des logis et Richard qui est en
fait le chef de pièce de ce canon César
voilà vous venez de voir et bien cette
d'assister enfin à cette revue de
troupes du président de la République
j'imagine que c'est un grand moment pour
vous oui oui c'est à la fois une fierté
un honneur de participer à ce défiler
c'est mon premier et surtout à une
fierté que depuis tout petit j'aurai la
télé et enfin j'ai participé mais
comment on se prépare à un événement
comme ça un défilé du 14 juillet quand
on est militaire
on est habitué plus ou moins là on a 7
jours d'entraînement sur une base à
répéter matin et après-midi et à force
c'est carré qu'est-ce que vous avez
ressenti au moment où vous avez vu et
bien le le président de la République
avec le chef d'état-major des armées et
puis le et puis le commandant militaire
de Paris ah ben un honneur d'être là un
honneur d'être là depuis le temps je
suis présent je suis acteur
alors vous allez tout à l'heure défiler
sur ces Champs-Élysées d'ici d'ici
quelques quelques minutes comment
comment ça va se passer là dans les
instants qui qui arrivent tous les
véhicules vont se mettre en place la
circulation va nous réguler mais petit à
petit en place dès que le premier avion
passe et après on va attendre
le finish alors vous êtes je le disais
le chef de pièce de ce canon César ça
veut dire que c'est vous finalement qui
qui allait gérer le fonctionnement de de
cette engin c'est ça oui tout à fait à
son bord on est cinq moi je gère la
pièce
dedans dans la cabine on a cinq
personnelles j'ai le pilote avec le
pourvoyeur j'ai un pointeur et un
deuxième pourvoyeur
on va peut-être faire le tour de ce
qu'annoncer parce que c'est vrai qu'on
en a beaucoup entendu parler de ces
qu'annoncésar notamment à l'occasion de
la de la gare en Ukraine expliquez-nous
un petit peu comment ça fonctionne bah
c'est un camion en fait César c'est un
canon équipé d'un système d'armes en
l'occurrence un canot de 155 mm il tire
des obus de 155 mm sur un châssis qui
pète en siromotrice selon les terrains
sable terre
dedans il y a un emporte de 18 obus donc
alors où est-ce qu'ils sont en fait les
obus et là dans les casiers 18 obus et
selon les effets demandés sur le terrain
ce soit tire d'éclairage de
neutralisation ou d'aveuglement on est
en mesure de parler à ça
on va continuer à faire le tour pour
visiter en tout cas comprendre comment
ça fonctionne précisément alors sur le
côté on a les obus l'autre côté on a des
charges
quand on a une demande de tir j'ai un
pourvoyeur qui ramène un obus ici sur la
le stabilisateur une personnelle le
prend le mets sur la civière
là je dis qu'il mette le but dans le
tube de l'autre côté j'ai pour varier
qui ramène une charge il la met dans le
tube j'ai mon pointeur il ferme la
culasse il se met sur les éléments et
après feu ça c'est votre rôle c'est vous
qui ordonnez le tir oui oui moi je suis
toujours en retrait et je gère que tout
se passe bien là que ça ça déroule ça
veut dire que vous n'êtes pas à bord au
moment au moment du tir non il y a
personne à bord les cinq personnelles
sont en arrière on va continuer
peut-être à faire le tour
donc là c'est l'autre côté module là
aussi on a un ordinateur dedans
le BHM c'est la moitié interface homme
machine c'est là où je reçois tous les
éléments de tir et qu'on voit si la
moindre erreur la moindre panne tout
s'affiche ici quel est le processus de
tir vous êtes en lien j'imagine avec
avec l'état-major oui on a un système
Atlas au automatisation automatisation
des tirs de liaison d'artillerie et en
fait il nous envoie des coordonnées ils
servent en temps normal ce qu'on a comme
obus en essence et où est-ce qu'on est
et c'est vous ensuite qui assurer le
lien finalement entre entre l'état-major
et le terrain on remonte les
informations eux ils voient où on est et
après en fonction de nos déplacements
ils nous disent ouais ce qu'on voit ce
que l'on fait
on va continuer peut-être ce petit tour
du canon César
donc là comme vous pouvez voir il y a
les deux roues quand il se met en
position de tir le stabilisateur descend
les deux roues ne touchent plus le sol
et après on met le tube selon les
coordonnées demandées les éléments
demandés
et là le poste de pilotage la cabine est
blindée
pour un canon César on parle à
proprement parler d'un pilote et non pas
et non pas d'un conducteur non non c'est
un pilote pilote exactement un équipage
qui est d'abord oui c'est ça comme moi
je suis un chef de pièce voilà merci
beaucoup en tout cas maréchelle des
logis voilà donc pour cette petite cette
petite visite on va dire en immersion
dans ce dans ce canon César on s'apprête
à défiler sur les Champs-Élysées à bord
donc de cet engin
merci beaucoup Timothée et pendant que
et merci au maréchal des logis pendant
que vous parliez justement
ont pris place la
fanfare qui
chargé de l'animation initiale donc 80
musiciens 14 pays plus la France donc
l'objectif aussi de cette animation là
c'est de montrer la solidarité
stratégique les partenariats de la
France donc c'est vraiment un
une volonté de montrer notre alliance et
notre solidarité stratégique avec les
pays européens et de l'OTAN avant de
après de laisser la une place pour l'un
en particulier
[Musique]
et on va laisser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mirage de des miracles de la réalisation
fait par nos confrères de l'AFP c'est
dans les airs pourquoi parce que
justement c'est le début du défilé
aérien qu'on va commenter avec le
colonel Yann mandreau bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous je précise que
vous êtes actuellement en poste dans une
institution qu'on appelle la direction
des ressources humaines de l'armée de
terre et qui est devenu une direction
stratégique aujourd'hui puisque le
recrutement est au cœur de la
préoccupation des armées les
recrutements et la fidélisation oui tout
à fait c'est une des problématiques
majeures des armées waouh ça l'a
toujours été mais ça les en particulier
à l'heure actuelle avec une loi de
programmation militaire ambitieuse et
donc une légère remontée des effectifs
et donc il s'agit de faire l'ensemble de
nos effectifs dans les prochaines années
donc c'est stratégiques sachant que dans
l'actuel loi de programmation militaire
d'ailleurs il y a une part importante
qui en tous les cas une attention
importante qui est accordée à
revalorisation salariale qui ont été
quand même un problème notamment avec le
logiciel Louvois dans les années 2017
plusieurs sujets mais effectivement dans
la prochaine loi de problème
programmation militaire il y a une part
importante sur
alors revalorisation salariale mesure de
conditions du militaire qui sont prises
en compte effectivement dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
qui permettra aux militaire notamment
d'être mieux rémunérés alors
on va continuer à parler toutes ces
questions là alors que la
une animation initiale prend fin avec un
peu de un peu de retard
et que les yeux vont quand même se lever
avant
d'avoir le défilé aérien et en
particulier la Patrouille de France on
espère qu'on nous verra
les avions décollés sachant que en plus
cette année la Patrouille de France est
particulièrement à particulièrement à
l'honneur
une question peut-être encore sur les
budgets des armées ou en tous les cas
sur les différentes
choses que l'on va que l'on va voir
aujourd'hui
c'est
alors on revient peut-être sur d'autres
questions puisqu'on voyait le Premier
ministre indien certains commentaires
nous disaient que l'Inde est menacé par
le Pakistan effectivement c'est ce que
nous disait tout à l'heure je vais le
noter c'est l'ennemi traditionnel de
l'Inde depuis l'indépendance de ces de
ces deux pays autour du statut du
Cachemire qui est une région qui
revendiquée par le Pakistan mais qui est
en territoire
un territoire indien on nous demandait
quels sont les autres pays qui ont
acheté des rafales on parlait
de l'Egypte effectivement et également
il y a la Grèce en Europe où il y a des
discussions
est-ce que dans les banlieues on regarde
en direct le Figaro bah oui à certaines
pires banlieue on regarde et on salue
tous ceux qui nous suivent en direct sur
le site du Figaro avec le colonel mandro
l'animation
justement nous disait tout à l'heure le
colonel les Muller c'est plusieurs pays
qui sont représentés et qui sont avec
alliés avec la France alors oui
effectivement l'ensemble des pays qui
sont présents ici sur cette animation
musicale était engagée avec nous dans le
Sahel soit au cours de l'opération
Serval s'auto cours de l'opération
barkham soit actuellement le en force de
partenariat avec avec le Tchad et le
Niger et donc été engagé avec nous
récemment en opération extérieure on va
reparler peut-être de ces opérations
extérieures parce que
notamment en particulier sur la partie
africaine l'Afrique va être encore à
l'honneur d'une façon un peu
particulière cette année alors via la
via la jeunesse et le lycée de défense
liste défense africains un certain
nombre de partenariats tous les lycées
qui ont défilé africains qui vont
défiler aujourd'hui sont binômés avec
des lycées militaires français et donc
c'est une façon de mettre en avant oui
Jumelais avec les lycées et c'est une
façon de mettre en avant la jeunesse et
la jeunesse africaine avec laquelle on
peut opérer
l'Afrique qui était à l'honneur et puis
en d'autres lycées militaires d'ailleurs
qui vont qui vont défiler tout à l'heure
les lycées militaires français on les
verra ensemble et on commettra ensemble
peut-être votre ancien glycémique
c'était quoi votre ancien lycée dans un
lycée militaire et donc du coup je fais
défauts
tout à fait vous avez vu parce qu'on
rappelle que justement c'est une
question qui peut qu'on peut à laquelle
on peut répondre d'ailleurs c'est
comment on devient comment on rentre on
peut rentrer dans l'armée comment on
peut suivre une carrière de ficier
aujourd'hui alors la façon de suivre une
carrière d'officier si je prends mon
exemple je suis sincérien donc je suis
rentré après des classes préparatoires
donc je souhaite mettre dessus maths
soit l'équivalent en écho ou en lettres
d'autres façons de rentrer c'est
officier sous contrat on verra tout à
l'heure l'école des officiers sous
contrats qui défilera ou le recrutement
interne la moitié de nos officiers sont
recrutement interne était auparavant
militaire durant ou sous-officier et
donc on commence comme militairement et
sous-officier via l'escalier social son
recrutés en interne pour pour devenir
officier le début du défilé aérien avec
la Patrouille de France
oui il fait aujourd'hui c'est c'est 70
ans véritable ambassadeur à seulement de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace mais
aussi de la France à l'international
c'est d'avoir l'image en grand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et le défilé aérien qui continue avec
qui met à l'honneur les 25 ans
partenariats stratégiques entre la
France et l'Inde c'était à ce moment là
d'ailleurs on doit avoir normalement on
va voir si on peut les voir les
rafales de l'armée indienne trois
rafales oui tout à fait on a vu quatre
rafales en images donc devant en
triangle trois rafales de l'armée
indienne suivi par un Rafale arafle
français
là effectivement c'est toujours un
exercice un peu difficile de de repérer
des avions et de voir un peu les avions
mais même dans les filmer donc là
maintenant on voit le centre d'expertise
aérienne militaire qui fait ses 90 ans
et donc avec un Rafale et deux mirages
intéressant le centre d'expertise
militaire parce que il assure la
réflexion prospective et il participe à
l'analyse des modes d'action russe il y
a un grand travail en ce moment sur le
retour d'expérience de la guerre de la
guerre en Ukraine et là maintenant on
voit passer un nawax et dorafal et de
mirages qui illustrent la protection de
l'espace aérien la police du ciel une
des deux missions principales de l'armée
de l'espace la mission d'allawax on
rappelle peut-être ce que c'est c'est de
nos missions de renseignements
alors
la défense du territoire européen qui va
être également à l'honneur avec un
nouveau des des
missions des nations partenaires avec
les Britanniques et les Belges
qui défilent aux côtés de Rafale et de
Mirage 2000 français
[Musique]
comme ça passe très vite même les
officiels sont obligés de suivre les
guides c'est la défense des intérêts
vitaux stratégiques ainsi encore la
dissuasion qui est à l'honneur c'est
d'ailleurs une des fonctions très fortes
de l'Armée de l'Air oui c'est l'une des
deux missions principales avec la police
du ciel dont je parlais tout à l'heure
donc l'addition nucléaire qui est l'une
des deux missions principales de l'armée
de l'art et de l'espace que l'on voit
donc défiler avec un avion Phoenix et
trois rafales
la projection des forces également
dont est également soulignés cette année
on a une mission d'ailleurs qui
pense que c'est ce qu'on est en train de
voir exactement ça c'est notre capacité
alors là c'est encore l'armée de l'air
c'est notre capacité à s'engager en
premier dernier exemple en date la
mission Sagittaire au Soudan avec
l'évacuation de plus de 800
ressortissants dont 200 français qui
illustré là par ce tableau de l'arménien
en gros si on reprend l'Armée de l'Air
vous parliez de mission principale il y
a la mission d'elle de police du ciel
notamment les Russes ont donné pas mal
de travail
plus récemment récemment mais toutes ces
dernières années on sent qu'ils essayent
toujours de de frôler l'espace aérien
plus récemment ce qui a fait l'actualité
c'est le 24 juin dernier avec un Rafale
qui interceptait un avion qui est
transporté de la drogue et anecdote
d'ailleurs le pilote du Rafale est à
rester un ancien de la Patrouille de
France qui a qui a défini en tête du
défilé aérien tout à l'heure donc ça
c'est la mission de police du ciel une
mission également de de protection
de également de dissuasion c'est à dire
que c'est aussi
la simplement tactique il y a quelques
elle joue un rôle dans la dans la
stratégie et en tout cas la stratégie de
dissuasion non tellement dissuasion
nucléaire mais la dissuasion militaire
au sens plus classique au sens classique
et aussi notamment au la dissuasion
nucléaire ou l'Armée de l'Air s'entraîne
régulièrement via des exercices poker
une cinquantaine d'avions qui s'entraîne
à simuler au sein du territoire national
un rende nucléaire pour s'exercer à
cette capacité et puis la mission vous
le lisez également la mission de
transport en particulier de transport
sur et de projections de force ce qu'on
appelle la projection c'est de pouvoir
débarquer sur un sur un terrain oui tout
à fait soit de projection de force
projeter des forces françaises comme on
a pu le faire en entrée au Mali en 2013
soit sur l'évacuation de ressortissants
dont on parlait tout à l'heure alors
on est
[Musique]
là sur l'intervention la capacité
d'intervention de la France avec l'un
des mirages et un Rafale des bases de
Nancy et Istres qui sont en train de
défiler
[Musique]
nous avons là le groupe aérien en bac
embarqué qui a composé aérienne du
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle dernier
opération majeure pour le porte-avion
Charles de Gaulle qui était en océan
Indien avec des exercices avec les
armées indiennes et Sega singapourienne
notamment
alors c'est
effectivement
c'est un point important à aborder pour
le Premier ministre avec le Premier
ministre indien puisque on est au cœur
du partenaire du partenariat avec la
stratégie avec l'Inde et des commandes
d'avion de Rafale et de cette de ce
nouveau porte-avion indien qui va
falloir équiper
[Musique]
et on voit effectivement Emmanuel Macron
faire le guide et l'article
oui tout à fait et donc là
illustrer deux Atlantes League 2 et un
Falcon de la marine d'un côté le
renseignement qui vient du ciel pour
pour la marine et de l'autre la lutte
contre les trafics et la pollution
maritime
[Musique]
alors avant de revoir les derniers
groupes aériens
un témoignage de Christian alors là
mais toujours c'est la formation qui est
également à l'honneur
alors logiquement on va suivre derrière
l'école d'aviation de chasse qui est
basé à Cognac qui s'est transformé en
profondeur ces dernières années avec une
formation encore plus efficiente qui
intègre davantage de simulation et pour
la petite anecdote qui permet de réduire
l'empreinte carbone de formation des
futurs pilotes de chasse de 70 % ce qui
est quand même pas négligeable l'école
de Cognac d'ailleurs qui sera l'honneur
dans le dans le défilé
avec les autres écoles de formation
parce qu'on en découvre plein Christian
Léon nous fait nous donne ce témoignage
pour le service national on pouvait
choisir de préparer des oor les écoles
d'officiers et de réserve on faisait
alors 18 mois que possibilité
d'engagement dans l'armée c'est toujours
le cas
que l'on voit là encore les
effectivement qui est en train de
[Musique]
passer au dessus de la tribune officiel
et là suivez par donc l'école de
transport tout à fait qui suit l'école
d'aviation de chasse 4 bousing dessus
le xinium c'est
rechercher justement
et donc l'avion utilisé par l'école
d'avion
[Musique]
alors que le défilé aérien touche à sa
fin alors important le Dash 8 de la
sécurité civile qu'on va voir oui qui
arrive juste derrière qui devrait
participer cet été à l'opération
Héphaïstos qui suit une double
modification cette année aux
modifications temporelle elle va
s'étendre jusqu'au 37 septembre c'est la
mission de lutte contre les incendies et
géographique elle va s'étendre à toute
la France avec la capacité de
l'intervenir sur l'ensemble du
territoire national en cas de risque
d'incendie on voit défiler là en ce
moment
[Musique]
et donc le défi le dernier
défilé avec
des avions qui représentent qui
représentent l'excellence des pilotes
français avec deux pilotes qui ont fini
aux deux premières places du championnat
du monde de voltige l'an dernier
prochain rendez-vous pour eux en
septembre avec les championnats d'Europe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de défense d'Afrique qui sont qui sont
mises à l'honneur
[Musique]
alors
je croyais que les mirages de l'île
avaient été retiré du service
voilà on a une transformation au fur et
à mesure comme l'ensemble des armées
c'est à dire qu'on ne relève pas d'un
seul en un seul bloc l'ensemble des
équipements et donc on a une
transformation progressive de l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace leur rafale qui
reprend la place des anciens avions
comme les mirages f1r pour la
reconnaissance remplacé par les rafales
et donc au fur et à mesure les mirages
vont disparaître du service être
remplacés par les rafales j'ai hâte nous
demande à ce qu'on verra des drones
autonomes demain dans l'armée française
pour l'instant on a des précisé le terme
de drones autonome par exemple alors oui
on a des alors il n'y en aura pas en
défilé aujourd'hui on a des drones armés
au sein des armées la volonté lors de la
loi prochaine loi de programmation
militaire et donc qui maintient une
volonté qu'on a depuis plusieurs années
c'est que l'homme gardera toujours le
contrôle sur le drone ou sur le ou sur
le robot on garde la main on aura jamais
un véhicule ou un drone complètement
autonome alors là justement ce sont les
armées étrangères qui sont à l'honneur
et donc et donc le prix tanné militaire
de Saint-Louis au Sénégal à sa tête que
ça les Indiens quand même oui pardon
excusez-moi
le régiment de Punjab donc 240
militaires pour illustrer le le
partenariat entre le la France et l'Inde
partenariat qui fête ses 25 ans il a une
deuxième fois que que l'un de défilent
sur le Champs-Élysées après après 2009
[Musique]
donc les trois armées indiennes sont
représentés au cours de défilé l'armée
de terre l'armée de l'air et la marine
[Musique]
c'est étonnant où on voit le Premier
ministre indien salué faire le salut
militaire ce que ne fait jamais le
président de la République en France et
oui costume militaire différentes selon
les pays on voit c'est aussi souvent le
président américain salué chose qui ne
se fait traditionnellement pas en France
notamment parce qu'on s'allume pas
traditionnellement sans coiffe militaire
donc voilà des des cultures militaires
différentes selon les pays
alors ce sont les autres troupes
étrangères enfin en tous les cas
pays étrangers qui sont mis à l'honneur
et ce sont les
différents lycées militaires qui sont
aujourd'hui
on découvre qu'il y a pas mal de lycées
militaires en Afrique
qui comme il y a comme il en existe
comme une existent en France et ce sont
des lycées vous disiez qui sont parfois
jumelés avec les lycées
avec avec les lycées avec les lycées
français illustrent le partenariat qu'on
a avec ses écoles et le lien de
confiance qu'on a dès le lycée puis
ensuite dans les écoles militaires
que l'on voit encore les troupes
à Vienne
alors donc première à gauche on voit
donc le à gauche le pritanné militaire
de saint Louis Sénégal qui fait ses 100
ans aujourd'hui à sa tête le col Mamour
ça qui est saint-cyrien et qui défilé
sur les Champs-Élysées il y a très
exactement 20 ans donc ça doit être
quelque chose pour lui de revenir
défiler aujourd'hui 20 ans 20 ans après
la tête à la tête de du lycée Charles de
Saint-Louis quatre anciens présidents à
ceux du Bénin de Guinée Conakry du
Centrafrique et du Niger l'actuel chef
d'état-major des armées du Sénégal
le 3 ministre du gouvernement actuel du
Sénégal sont issus de notamment son prix
issus de ce cutané également l'écrivain
MBU
m-garp SAR pardon qui a été pris
Goncourt 2021 Madagascar qui était
également à l'honneur qui fait aussi ses
100 ans c'est 100 ans dans la pour le
coup dans quelques jours qui prépare les
futurs candidats aux grandes écoles
militaires la Côte d'Ivoire avec une
devise qui rappelle celle de Saint-Cyr à
s'instruire pour mieux servir l'école
militaires donc de Bingerville 700
élèves un tiers de filles et il faut
savoir que 90% des officiers
ivres Ivoiriens ont fait ce lycée donc
c'est vraiment le creuset des futurs
officiers du pays des futurs élites
[Musique]
et là ce sont les écoles
françaises qui sont
à l'honneur
[Musique]
oui des lycées d'excellence qui
remplissent une mission d'aide à la
famille des militaires dans le
secondaire et l'appui heureusement des
futurs cadres grâce à leur classe
préparatoire aux grandes écoles pour
préparer les concours en notamment des
grandes écoles militaires
à noter plusieurs dossiers qui font
partie des 30 meilleurs lycées français
le lycée militaire de Saint-Cyr-l'École
lycée militaire d'Aix-en-Provence ou le
prytané national militaire de La Flèche
[Musique]
et le début du défilé à plier avec
en-tête le général adjoint engagement
général Chasseboeuf ancien parachutiste
qui a notamment commandé le 8e régiment
parachutiste d'infanterie de marine
[Musique]
qui dans son rôle actuel aura un rôle
prépondérant lors des prochains jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
occasionneront
un déplacement du défilé l'an prochain
donc entre Vincennes et la place de la
Nation comme l'a annoncé Emmanuel Macron
hier soir
[Musique]
s de
dans les états majeur
et également dans le cabinet du
gouverneur militaire de Paris
on devait avoir l'École polytechnique
qui devrait défiler en tête maintenant
de
comme chaque année école d'excellence ça
devise pour la patrie les sciences et la
gloire fortement ouvert sur
l'international avec près de 40% de
d'enseignants et d'étudiants étrangers
et avec le célèbre bicorne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
fondation la Révolution et militariser
par Napoléon 1804
c'est lui qui avait donné justement
cette devise et ce drapeau oui tout à
fait
initialement c'était davantage les
officiers destinés aux armes techniques
qui servent les techniques ceux de
l'artillerie notamment
on voit derrière arriver l'école des
officiers de la Gendarmerie nationale
que le Melun
créé en 1901 école de formation de
l'ensemble des officiers de gendarmerie
que ce soit près une grande école
militaire ou après un cursus academic
classique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
direction du colonel Soum des faucons
qui est directeur des enseignements à
l'école des Melun de Melun pardon
une promotion qui a un vieux nom qui est
Duguesclin
[Musique]
ça vous avez peut-être pouvoir nous
indiquer la musique qu'on est en train
d'entendre c'est la galette des musiques
traditionnellement jouer à saint-cyrin
on entend juste derrière et donc
justement arrive derrière l'école
spéciale militaire de Saint-Cyr en tête
le col pavlowski directeur de la
formation des élèves
suivi du commandant de bataillon du
premier bataillon de France le col
Zeller derrière la gare de drapeaux donc
au petit anecdote celui qui porte le
drapeau et le major de de sa promotion
avec les élèves les mieux placés autour
de lui derrière les dernières années qui
dans quelques jours vont rejoindre leur
école d'applications avant de rejoindre
leur régiment dans un an
nos écoles d'application d'armée de
terre ça peut être aussi bien
l'infanterie la cavalerie là où on a
pris ou la gendarmerie est donc
rejoindre rejoint le Melun qu'on voyait
défiler juste avant
alors Saint-Cyr se trouve sur le camp
militaire de code qui dan en
Morbihan avec deux autres écoles
militaire un terrain qui représente
l'escalier social au sein de l'armée de
terre je vous parlais du recrutement
interne tout à l'heure pour les
officiers
hier ce qui défile il y a 2 ans très
exactement été militaire durant ou
sous-officier l'an prochain ils seront
chef de section
à la tête d'une section de 30 à 40
personnes
[Musique]
alors un autre d'ailleurs
une autre une autre voix de recrutement
puisqu'on a l'école militaire des
aspirants de coïti dans c'est ce qui
correspond aux anciens oor on peut on
peut dire ça c'est les officiers sous
contrat donc l'école est écrit en 2021
mais elle reprend des officiers sous
contrat et existaient depuis bien avant
et donc ces dossiers sous contrat soit
encadrement qui vont encadrer des
troupes soit spécialistes pour servir
dans dans les états majors dans des
domaines particuliers donc l'école
elle-même est créée en 2021 et sur le
camp de coachidant avec les deux autres
écoles qu'on a vu défiler juste avant
c'est sûr que ce sont des volontaires
qui font une formation officier quel est
le quels sont les qualifications en tous
les cas quels sont les niveaux d'études
requis avant pour pouvoir rentrer dans
justement dans ce genre d'école on est
du entre le niveau bac + 3 Bac à Bac + 5
oral un nom ensuite c'est pour être
comme ici sous contrat on passe
on les épaules sa candidature et ensuite
on a sélectionné on a sélectionné sur
sur dossier et ensuite en fonction de là
où on est recruté soit de spécialiste
soit encadrement on a une formation
entre quatre mois et un an et quoi
dedans pour se préparer à ses
responsabilités futures
[Musique]
on passe à la marine l'École navale
célèbre école navale
qui adoptait une nouvelle devise en 2021
pour la France par les maires nous
combattons qui remplace la précédente
obéir avant de avant de commander
ça reste
ça reste un principe quand même
intéressant
et on voit maintenant
le pendant de Saint-Cyr pour l'Armée de
l'Air et de l'Espace l'école de l'air et
de l'espace quelle école de
Salon-de-Provence oui tout à fait avec
une devise célèbre faire face du
Capitaine Guynemer qui est un des
aviateurs les plus célèbres pilotes de
la Première Guerre mondiale tombée au
champ d'honneur en 2017 vous précisez
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant que c'est
une école de l'Air et de l'Espace parce
que justement bien ce terrain si je puis
dire prends une place prépondérante oui
en particulier dans dans les nouvelles
formes de guerre une nouvelle forme de
conflictualité tout à fait donc c'est
l'Armée de l'Air anciennement armé de
l'air qui a récupéré ce champ dans son
domaine de responsabilité on voit aussi
un vrai forfait au cours de la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire avec un
effort budgétaire dans ce domaine pour
pour garder une avance dans ce domaine
alors d'autres écoles continuent de
défiler on va peut-être essayer de
rejoindre Timothée d'Hélène qui lui
s'apprête à descendre les
Champs-Élysées ou le soleil semble-t-il
est revenu
[Musique]
sans que c'est l'école des commissaires
des armées je veux pas dire de bêtises
cousin donc ça encore l'école de
l'étoile de l'air on sait c'était
l'école nationale supérieure des
techniques avancées de Bretagne
[Musique]
au milieu il forme à la fois des
ingénieurs civils et militaires de qui
auront vocation suite à servir au sein
de la Direction générale de l'armement
pour concevoir et mettre en bas en
oeuvre nos programmes d'armement qui
équipent les armées alors l'école des
commissaires des armées défilent et on a
également à l'image Timothée délai dans
tous les cas ce que voit sa caméra
Timothée vous êtes prêt embarqué
[Musique]
oui absolument Vincent nous sommes nous
sommes près de nous n'attendons plus que
le top départ vous le voyez les
véhicules qui se sont qui se sont mises
en place alors que le pilote à la
gentillesse de couper le moteur parce
que c'est vrai que sinon on peine à
s'entendre et voilà on se tient prêt
donc pour pour démarrer ce défilé le
défilé des troupes motorisés qui est
prévu pour 11h33 même si il semble que
le que le protocole est pris un petit
peu de retard ici l'enjeu ça va être
évidemment et bien de de faire une belle
colonne pendant tout ce défiler les
Champs-Élysées à peu près 2 km de
descente avec une moyenne de 14 à 15
km/h pendant tout ce défilé la descente
qui devrait qui devrait durer 13 minutes
ça c'est ce que me confier tout à
l'heure le le pilote de ce de ce canon
César voilà le dispositif en tout cas
est en place et nous n'attendons plus et
bien que que ce soit à notre tour de
défiler sur ces Champs-Élysées
merci Timothée alors que le défilé lui à
pied continue et on vient de voir passer
il me semble la fameuse école du service
de santé des armées oui avec trois
écoles qui défilaient l'école du Val De
Grasse l'école de santé des armées
l'école du personnel par médical des
armées on a une salutation au colonel
Nicolas Zeller qui est venu sur sur
plateau déjà nous présenter justement le
le métier de peut-être qui nous fera un
message
on voit quand même à toutes les toutes
les la formation qu'il y a dans les
armées c'est que cette impressionnant
dans ce défilé on voit les encore les
gendarmes l'école de gendarmerie de
Montluçon qui est cette fois-ci l'école
le pendant en tout cas sous-officier de
l'école de Melun que l'on a vu passer
tout à fait sur la formation initiale
des futurs gendarmes et gendarme adjoint
volontaire
[Musique]
commandé par le général Laurent Vidal
et puisqu'on parle des sous-officiers il
y a une très vieille école qui est très
connue qui est
l'école des officiers d'actifs de
Saint-Maixent maison-mère des officiers
de l'armée de terre qui fait aujourd'hui
son 60e anniversaire
et pendant ce temps-là vous voyez le
défilé
aérien se prépare avec les hélicoptères
autre institution que j'ai découvert à
cette occasion qui est l'école
interarmée des sports oui tout à fait
une double vocation pour voir cette
unité interarmée former les moniteurs
des sports des trois armées et soutenir
les 41 équipes de France qui rayonnent
dans les compétitions internationales
[Musique]
ça m'excent qui va former près de 6800
sous-officiers cette année contre 6500
l'année précédente
c'est un concours également d'entrée à
Saint-Maixent alors recrutement soit en
interne par la voix militaire du rang
donc on commence comme militaire du rond
on est recruté ensuite comme comme
sous-officier soit une nouvelle fois on
se présente on pose un dossier de
candidature pour être recruté comme
comme sous-officier de possibilités soit
en interne soit en recrutement externe
on peut le passage de sous-officier
comme officier se fait facilement donc
un concours interne qu'on a vu passer
donc le concours de l'École militaire
interne ce qui défilait tout à l'heure
juste derrière les écoles de Saint-Cyr
coïté dans un concours exigeant mais
mais possible on rentre pas directement
à l'école militaire d'un terrain il faut
être passé par Saint-Maixent
le recrutement semis direct l'escalier
social on peut le repasser soit de
passer par Saint-Maixent soit être
militaire durant et aussi une voix pour
les militaires durant pour passer
directement officier via le concours de
l'École militaire interne
on parlez donc de l'école intérieure et
des Sports qui est connu de tous les
passionnés de sport parce que souvent
autrefois quand il y avait un service
militaire tous les champions étaient
passés par bataillon de Joinville on a
toujours des grands sportifs à
l'intérieur et savoir les notamment
qu'il défile aujourd'hui à noter que la
moitié des médaillés des derniers Jeux
Olympiques et paramètres olympiques
étaient membres de de des sportifs
militaires
[Musique]
ou Anaïs Bescond pour le pour le
biathlon l'école de mestrance
[Musique]
qui l'école des sous-officiers de la
marine donc le pendant de Saint-Maixent
pour la Marine qui est créé depuis
1900-1933 et qui donc défilent défilent
aujourd'hui qui fait de cette année
c'est 70 ans
et on ne va avoir dans un instant très
naturellement après avoir les
sous-officiers de l'armée de terre de la
Marine et bien ceux de l'Armée de l'Air
oui de l'espace l'école créa un an plus
tôt que celle de mestrant en 1932 sa
devise s'armer pour le futur et donc
elle forme à la fois les sauciers de
l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace qui a
une formation technique et
professionnelle et une formation
générale
alors
un certain nombre de commentaires un peu
acerbe je vois sur le sur le chat c'est
c'est le débat c'est le commentaire si
les libertés d'expression tant que ça
reste dans le cadre des
des
sortes de modération et bien bien
entendu toutes les opinions sont
entendables
c'est un autre me dit les citoyens ne
veulent pas de défiler mais des actes
pour restaurer la paix civils en France
cet état effectivement autre opinion
expression et on pourrait vous rapporter
d'ailleurs sur les sondages qui sont
publiés sur le site du Figaro qui nous
ont rendu public hier le défilé le
continue donc l'école des sous-officiers
de la l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
l'école des fusillés marins également
qui est qui est à l'honneur ce matin on
est en 1856 avec chaque nouvelle
promotion de la fusible marin qui est
basée au nom d'un fusil marin mort pour
la France je suis derrière le premier
régiment d'infanterie de la garde
républicaine
[Musique]
donc le seul qui a le droit de rendre
les honneurs au président de la
République
[Musique]
par le Centre national d'entraînement
qu'on met en eau qui fête ses 60 ans à
sa tête le colle Damien Lefebvre
[Musique]
alors suivant on peut peut-être
d'ailleurs préciser à quoi sert le
fameux snack alors c'est un centre
d'agalisme ou passe à la fois les futurs
commandos et la plupart de nos cadres
pour pour s'aguerrir en vue de leur
responsabilités
c'est quelque chose d'assez spécifique
enfin je veux dire il y a pas beaucoup
de d'armées qui ont beaucoup de
stagiaires étrangers qui viennent même
américain qui viennent s'entraîner au
centre national d'entraînement commando
une vraie spécificité française on a vu
derrière défiler le 132e régiment
d'infanterie si nos techniques plus
grand d'unité sino-technique
opérationnelle d'Europe
puisqu'on peut être commando on
recommandera le livre agir ou subir de
Nicolas Monnet Raphaël Chauvency c'est
aux éditions Dunod comment l'esprit
commando peut justement servir si train
arrive très intéressant on en a parlé
ici sur ce plateau et justement c'est
l'occasion d'y revenir le 132e donc
régiment de l'infanterie ici nos
techniques et puis le deuxième régiment
parachutiste d'infanterie de marine très
intéressant parce que c'est c'est
également l'engagement de la France
outre-mer outre-mer tout à fait qui a
été créé donc le régiment créé en 1947 à
Tarbes et transfert à la Réunion en 1973
on voit encore le régiment qui termine
de défiler 132e pas de Taillon régiment
par non d'infanterie avec les chiens oui
tout à fait
un vrai binôme entre entre le soldat et
l'animal
et c'est eux qui gèrent d'ailleurs tout
le cheptel de chien de de 1 m à tous
Châtel mais l'essentiel on a ensuite
quelques régiments qui ont des
détachements cynophiles pour assurer
assurer la protection du site
on a donc là le 19e régiment du génie
qui défile ça devise entreprendre et
réussir régiment projeté récemment à
Saint-Martin après la tempête Irma en
2017 à Beyrouth en 2020 et plus
récemment en Roumanie en 2022 c'est lui
d'ailleurs qui était le premier régiment
qui qui allait sur
près du front ukrainien pour mettre en
place les
la future base opérationnelle
je suis derrière le commandement du
renseignement de force terrestre à quoi
ça sert alors fournir du renseignement
donc c'est un commandement qui agrège
l'ensemble des capacités de
renseignements de l'armée de terre
française donc à s'attaque le général de
division Guillaume Danès s'était créé il
y a 1500 personnes réagit entre 5
régiments deux centres et une école qui
qui vont défiler aujourd'hui qui sont
représentés juste après
alors Christmas la question nous revient
chaque année qui est combien coûte le
défilé il y a une partie qui est prise
en charge par les me semble on va on va
retrouver la formation mais vous avez un
article sur le site du Figaro qui répond
à toutes ces questions Kris Kross et
dont je vais pas vous dire des bêtises
parce que à chaque fois je me on
se trompe dans les chiffres dans la part
que chacun prend à l'organisation du
défilé mais je vous assure vous faites
sur le Le Figaro combien coûte le coût
du défilé du 14 juillet et vous avez la
réponse
les régiments d'autres régiments qui
sont à l'honneur aujourd'hui ce sont les
régiments de hussard oui deuxième
régiment de hussard créé en 1735 donc un
des régiments qui appartient au
renseignement des forces terrestres
et qui portent un béret brun la légende
veut que ça soit Marie-Antoinette qui
est choisi cette couleur
autre régiment important dans les
transmissions qu'on vient de voir à
passer il me semble c'est le 44e
régiment de transmission oui tout à fait
le régiment de guerre électronique et de
guerre électronique pardon qui est cité
à l'ordre de l'armée pour son engagement
en Afghanistan on les appelle les
veilleurs de l'imprévu tout à fait oui
on voit maintenant
suivre un détachement de réserviste donc
à droite de la 9e d'infanterie de marine
brigade d'intervention spécialiste des
opérations amphibie et spécialistes des
entrées en premier la majoritairement
des réservistes du sixième régiment du
génie qui est le régiment du génie de la
de la brigade et on recommande
d'ailleurs sur ce régiment
[Musique]
sur les réservistes pardon le reportage
tourné par Timothée délai que nous avons
déjà diffusé une première fois hier sur
la
Le Figaro TNT le Figaro TV sur la terre
sur la TNT Île-de-France mais vous
pouvez retrouver sur le site la brigade
des sapins de Paris
on a eu la sûreté ferroviaire d'ailleurs
qui a également défilé auparavant qui
est
la litière d'une institution que je
découvre à l'occasion de ce défilé qui
la police générale des chemins de fer
donc la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris sauver ou périr seule une unité
qui va défiler à la fois à pied et en
véhicule
la BSPP le plus grand encore de
sapeurs-pompiers d'Europe et le
troisième dans le monde après ceux de
Tokyo de New York
c'était particulièrement
sollicité notamment dans l'incendie de
Notre Dame
et plus récemment avec le décès du
sergent dame Lincourt qui aurait dû
d'ailleurs défilés à pied aujourd'hui et
qui est mort lors d'une intervention en
Seine-Saint-Denis dans un parking
vincendie sur un incendie
exactes si c'est lié non aux émeutes
là nous avons conjointement la flottille
amphibie à droite et le groupement
d'aide à l'engagement amphibie à gauche
les commandos enfilis de la sixième
brigade légère blindée avec en tête donc
le Turpin le chef de opération du 21e on
a vu à gauche
question
pourquoi porte-t-il des Caps alors là
c'est un c'est un Space donc c'est la
tenue de tradition du spy donc là c'est
le groupement le groupement d'aide à
l'engagement fini de la sixième brigade
légère blindée donc différents régiments
qu'on pose cette brigade dont le premier
space qui explique pourquoi vous avez
un soldat avec le
l'uniforme traditionnel des spahis le
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle derrière
qui qui défile fleurons de la marine
française et c'est tout le problème de
ces défilés c'est qu'on peut pas faire
défiler les bateaux donc ça serait
compliqué
[Musique]
le porte-avion Charles de Gaulle donc on
devrait qui va être qui sera lui
remplacé à quel horizon
alors j'ai plus les chiffres en tête
j'aurais dit on va confirmer ça tout à
l'heure Vincent vous le confirmera tout
à l'heure j'ai en tête horizon 2035 2035
2035 et on a toujours pas de nom pour
euh le prochain porte-avion j'en sais
pas plus que vous je pense qu'on a le
temps de choisir le nom
de la base Aéronautique navale de
Landivisiau la réplique terrestre du
porte-avion Charles de Gaulle surnommé
le porte-avion de granit
[Musique]
là encore la Marine a une fonction autre
d'une fonction militaire mais elle a
également une fonction stratégique et
elle a elle a une fonction également
même pour pour l'armée de terre dans
l'état d'opération avec un appuyant
enseignement oui tout à fait plusieurs
fonctions pour la marine fonction vous
avez parlé de la dissuasion l'action de
l'État en mer pendant de la police du
ciel de l'Armée de l'Air et de l'Espace
fonction aussi de transport de troupes
ce qu'on a vu tout à l'heure avec la
partie la partie amphibie et fonction
aussi de fournitures du renseignement
vous parlez à l'instant un apport pour
la souveraineté tout à l'heure une
question portée mais qu'est-ce que la
France fait dans la pourquoi la France
pourquoi l'Indo-Pacifique mais la France
est présente dans dans 2 millions de
Français vivent en Indo-Pacifique un
certain nombre de régiment et on est la
seule armée d'Europe à voir les forces
des forces permanentes basées en un
opacité
les forces sous-marines sont également à
l'honneur et elles ont également une
fonction stratégique notamment nucléaire
c'était justement le SNA améthyste un
des deux équipages qui
défilait l'équipage bleu du SNA
améthyste
[Musique]
alors on salue ns qui étaient présents
sur le chat et qui nous annonce qu'il
nous quitte mais il peut toujours
on peut toujours rester en faisant autre
chose même à côté
s'il n'y a pas les images qui est
dommage il y a toujours les commentaires
et donc puisqu'on parle une partie comme
on disait pour l'armée de l'air il y a
une partie pour la marine de protection
et la protection des approches maritimes
notamment au nord de la France et mise à
l'honneur aujourd'hui oui tout à fait et
la Marine qui est en train de conclure
son défi à pied qui suit par l'Armée de
l'Air la base aérienne 113 de
Saint-Dizier
il participe elle à l'ensemble des
missions de l'armée de l'espace qu'on a
écrit tout à l'heure également la
fameuse aérienne de Cognac
Châteaubernard qui également a une place
importante dans le rôle important dans
la formation oui tout à fait
actuellement en plein essor autour de
projet structurants vous parliez de la
formation donc la mortalité
modernisation de la formation des
équipages
de combat de l'armée de l'espace c'est
la montée en puissance de la partie
surveillance avec les drones Reaper et
la 33e escape de surveillance de
renseignement et d'attaque
alors on va rejoindre une dernière fois
avant qu'il commence à s'embarquer
Timothée d'elle qui se trouve alors que
on voit la direction générale Direction
générale de l'armement et les groupes de
soutiennent de défense qui sont derrière
là on est encore sur la partie armée de
l'air et on devine derrière la partie
Direction générale de l'armement juste
après qui défilent pour la première fois
cette année
et qui effectivement c'est une première
pour la direction générale de la France
sa création c'est la première fois
qu'elle défile sur les champs et les
Élysée donc un grand moment pour pour
ces femmes et ces hommes
alors Timothée en attendant de voir les
images de la Direction générale de
l'armement vous êtes sur le départ
oui Vincent sur le départ voilà on s'est
même on a même commencé à s'avancer un
petit peu sur cette célèbre avenue des
Champs-Élysées vous la voyez juste
devant nous là-bas tout au fond c'est
évidemment la tribune présidentielle ou
se tient le chef de l'État et nous
sommes donc à bord nous sommes prêts à
partir vous voyez ici le pilote qui est
qui est tout à fait prêt et toujours le
maréchal des logis Richard qui est le
chef de pièce en de ce de ce canon César
qui va nous expliquer parce que c'est
vrai que il y a une un élément important
dans ce défilé c'est c'est la dimension
et bien évidemment visuelle esthétique
il y a même vous me disiez des des
lignes bleues en fait qui ont été
tracées sur les Champs-Élysées pour et
bien que l'on reste bien bien droit bien
en ligne oui effectivement pour qu'on
reste bien en place on a plusieurs
repères au sol
pour en l'occurrence là juste devant des
petits pointillés bleu qui doivent
passer au milieu du châssis et ainsi que
des lignes pour contrer les véhicules il
y ait bien va mettre donc tous les 20
mètres il y a une ligne bleue et aussi
entre les modules à partir de 1200
mètres il faut 120 mètres entre les
modules donc tout à partir 1200 mètres
il y a un panneau tous les 120 mètres
pour voir et apprécier la distance entre
les modules quelle va être votre rôle
pendant le défilé comment est-ce que
vous vous partagez la tâche entre entre
le pilote qui est évidemment aux
manettes aux commandes et vous et vous à
côté mon pilote lui c'est il reste sur
l'axe que le véhicule reste axé sur
cette ligne et moi je je max sur le
véhicule qui est à ma gauche de l'autre
César qu'on soit bien aligné délaissant
va mettre jusqu'à la tribune
présidentielle il y a dans le véhicule
actuellement c'est vrai un peu un peu de
silence on imagine peut-être un peu de
stress au moment au moment où on
s'apprête à défiler comme ça devant la
foule sur les Champs-Élysées et puis
évidemment devant le chef de l'État ah
oui absolument même si on a répété
est prévu des cas au cas où il y a des
incidents mais on sait jamais si elle
peut arriver allez on va peut-être
abuser un tout petit peu de la
disponibilité de l'équipage on va se
tourner vers le pilote juste quelques
mots qu'est-ce qui prédomine c'est
plutôt le stress ou la fierté d'être là
aujourd'hui moi je dirais que c'est la
fierté quand même
voilà grande fierté donc vous l'avez
bien compris Vincent pour ce pour ce
défilé militaire on s'apprête maintenant
à descendre ces Champs-Élysées d'ici
quelques instants
merci merci beaucoup Timothée et on a
pendant que vous parliez et bien
justement les derniers corps
ont défilé les corps
d'armée et le corps des armées mais
également d'autres institutions
notamment là on est en train de voir il
me semble la police nationale et l'École
nationale de police de
Saint-Cyr-au-Mont-d'Or oui tout à fait
le drapeau de la police avec un majeur
qui est le porte-drapeau qui est
responsable d'unités local de police
c'est 5 autres défilant qui
l'accompagnent suivi par l'École
nationale supérieure de police qui a été
créé en 1941 ça devise courage
dévouement intégrités excellence
exemplarité École Nationale de Police de
Périgueux on a vu également tout à
l'heure
les
la direction de la maintenance
aéronautique et
un clin d'oeil à notre directeur
technique Jean-Pierre vernelder notre
excellent directeur technique qui a son
service militaire dans la maintenance
aéronautique et on peut témoigner que ça
donne de très très beaux fruits
on a vu le drapeau de la police
d'ailleurs et également également à
l'honneur cette année oui tout à fait
qui défile en tête des troupes pour pour
le playstation nationale il poursuit son
défilé
et que l'École Nationale Supérieure
d'application de la police nationale qui
assure les formations des gardiens de la
paix policiers adjoint et cadets de la
République
[Musique]
un autre corps qui est bien connu dans
la région de parisienne habitants de
Versailles notamment le bataillon des
sapeurs pompiers de France
oui tout à fait donc qui a été créé en
1977 cette école qui forme chaque année
près de 6000 officiers du corps des
sapeurs-pompiers en vocation ensuite à
servir sur l'ensemble du territoire or
Paris et Marseille qui sont des
sapeurs-pompiers militaires la BSPP et
le bataillon des marins-pompiers de
Marseille
[Musique]
donc alors qu'on a les images encore de
l'École nationale des officiers de
sapeur-pompiers
qui est donc suivi de ce 16e bataillon
des sapeurs-pompiers de France
alors d'autres
d'autres institutions sont on disait
tout à l'heure de la police mais
d'autres institutions sont mises à
l'honneur et notamment
l'administration pénitentiaire
les doigts aussi font partie des
institutions qui sont mises à l'honneur
chaque année sur sur le défilé du 14 du
14 juillet
et on a vu tout à l'heure les les
hélicoptères commencent à voler
mais ça ne on ne les verra réellement
qu'après avoir vu les pionniers de la
Légion étrangère qui clôtureront ce
défiler alors que là c'est
l'administration pénitentiaire qui est à
l'honneur avec 49 personnes qui
personnel de surveillance et élève
surveillants qui sont qui défilent
derrière la directrice du centre
pénitentiaire de Mont-de-Marsan madame
Vanessa prend pas et suivi donc de la
direction générale des douanes et des
droits indirects
[Musique]
et douane qui sont finalement un corps
de souveraineté puisque c'est
l'administration des frontières parce
qu'il en reste oui tout à fait avec le
bataillon donc on voit des conseillers
de 50 Dossiers volontaires qui sont
postes dans toute la France et qui
appartiennent à différentes composantes
composantes surveillance opération
commerciale et aussi administration
générale
alors ce sont généralement les gagnants
à l'applaudimètre lors des défilés les
pionniers de la Légion étrangère vont
défiler avec une particularité on les
voit
c'est qu'il défile moins vite que les
autres militaires alors c'est pas leur
seule particularité donc effectivement
il défile moins vite l'autre
particularité comme vous pouvez le voir
sont les pionniers donc qui est défilent
et c'est les seuls à porter la barbe
alors pourquoi parce que initialement
c'est eux qui ouvraient les routes qui
ouvraient les colonnes et donc il
n'avait pas le temps nécessaire pour se
raser donc c'est les seuls qui avaient
l'autorisation de porter la barbe vu
qu'il n'avait pas le temps qu'ils
étaient cœurs l'ouvrage très tôt le
matin jusque très tard le soir il
n'avait pas le temps de se raser donc
traditionnellement ils avaient le droit
de porter la barbe et donc du coup
chaque année ceux qui sont désignés un
an à l'avance comment ça se laisser à
pousser la barbe pour être prêt le jour
du 14 juillet
ils ont également ils portent donc le
tablier et une hache la hache les gants
sans les outils de travail pour ce corps
créé en 1831 et qui devient les
attributs de parade depuis 1930 depuis
[Musique]
les pionniers nous voyons les musiciens
de la Légion étrangère qui aimeraient
rayonnement international qui serait
récemment produit en Norvège ou en
Allemagne
articularité de ces musiciens ils ont
une double qualification ils sont aussi
entraînés au métier des armes ils sont
envoyés en opération qu'ils ont ainsi
participé cette année à l'opération
sentinelle à Toulouse en renfort du
Premier Régiment étranger de génie
peut-être le point le moment de faire un
point sur les opérations en cours donc
il y a la l'opération sentinelle sur le
territoire national
cette année a été on a vu l'Afrique et à
l'honneur mais d'un autre côté cette
année c'est aussi l'année où la France
s'est retirée quand même des théâtres
africains en particulier se retirent de
théâtre africains en particulier du
Maïli de la bande-salé au salarienne je
ne verrai pas les choses comme ça je
dirais qu'on redéploie notre dispositif
en fonction des besoins de nos
partenaires on a vu un rôle déploiement
de force sur sur nos partenaires pour
nos forces prépositionner et un
redéploiement aussi avec la fin de
l'opération barkhane et on maintient
quand même des forces volume 2500 à peu
près soldats ou Niger et au chat en
force partenaire de de ces pays dans
cette zone
les autres opérations extérieures la
France est encore déployée en Irak alors
oui l'opération chamall est toujours en
cours de composantes une aide à la
formation au manteau ring qui se
poursuit et aussi une composante
aérienne et une frégate qui sont qui
sont dans la zone un volume d'environ
600 600 militaires pour cette opération
chamale voilà et autres opérations
emblématique c'est l'opération de
réassurance à l'est avec environ 1400
soldats français qui sont déployés dans
les pays baltes évidemment un régiment
qui est déployé un papillon qui est
déployé en Roumanie et ensuite ce qu'on
voyait tout à l'heure défiler la police
les fonctions de protection du ciel avec
nos rafales qui sont déployés
ponctuellement à l'est bien entendu on
le rappelle la France est déployée
autour du théâtre Russo ukrainien mais
n'est pas déployée dans tous les cas
officiellement sur ce terme non plus oui
effectivement on a des déployés en
Roumanie ou en Estonie
voilà la légende étrangère qui finit de
défiler sur le dernier bloc le
commandant la Légion étrangère le
général le division Alain Lardy
ensuite un bloc de termine d'ailleurs
son commandement à la tête du café le
père Légion étrangère
et c'est le défilé aérien qui va
continuer où on voit les hélicoptères
effectivement les voir au loin à arriver
sur les Champs-Élysées
[Musique]
avec
quelques notamment des Puma et
des Fennec canon et un fennec et
un hélicoptère h160
on va regarder ces défilant
l'hélicoptère merci beaucoup en tous les
cas
pour avoir fait cette première partie du
défilé on vous retrouve à la fin à tout
à l'heure merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors je pense que nous sommes en train
de voir le tableau sur l'opération
d'envergure donc c'est plutôt le
troisième régiment d'hélicoptère de
combat donc avec des matériels à la fois
d'anciennes génération donc les Pumas et
les cougars et du matériel de nouvelle
génération avec les tigres et les
caïmans ou NH90 donc ce qu'il faut
retenir mais pour ce on a vu au
préalable enfin la partie
force aérienne de la gendarmerie
nationale là on est sur la partie
terrestre 70% donc des hélicoptères de
de
désarmés sont dans l'armée de terre et
la latte l'aviation légère de l'armée
terre faite l'année prochaine c'est 60
ans
donc le troisième RHC troisième régiment
hélicoptère de combat et mis à l'honneur
cette année il se rapprochait en fin
d'année au Niger comme on l'a évoqué
juste avant en faisant le point un peu
sur les opérations
les hélicoptères c'est essentiel
j'imagine dans les dans les opérations
alors les hélicoptères c'est clé dans
toutes les opérations aérotes donc pour
l'avoir vécu très personnellement au
combat lorsqu'on est au sol proche de
l'ennemi c'est pour nous une assurance
un appui de renseignement ça nous permet
vraiment de savoir où est-ce que nous en
où est-ce que nous en sommes où est-ce
que ce positionne l'adversaire où est-ce
que se positionne l'ennemi et donc c'est
vraiment une pour nous une assurance une
assurance vie au-delà de l'entraînement
qu'on peut avoir donc une vraie
complémentarité entre les troupes qui
sont au sol les hélicoptères de combat
qui sont dans les airs avec lesquels on
communique en permanence pour pouvoir
produire des effets
converger sur le terrain
alors on voit la police nationale qui
était à l'honneur actuellement
alors que s'apprête à défiler les
troupes motorisées sous la direction du
général Rémy cadapaux un dernier des
tours par
Timothée délai qui lui s'apprête à
défiler avec le canon César est-ce que
vous êtes déjà parti
et bien à l'instant même Vincent voilà
vous le voyez peut-être sur ces sur ces
images le véhicule qui est qui essaye et
qui est parti et nous savons donc
commencé à défiler et c'est vrai que
c'est assez impressionnant parce qu'on
voit une foule assez compacte sur les
sur les bords de ces Champs-Élysées avec
évidemment beaucoup de d'appareil photo
et de smartphone qui sont de sortie
voilà et vous voyez donc ici la la
parade qui qui vient de commencer pour
nous et évidemment et bien on fait très
attention à à garder et bien la bonne
distance voilà le le là on vient de nous
dire de ralentir un tout petit peu voilà
donc c'est vrai qu'on fait on fait très
attention il y a quelque chose d'assez
impressionnant parce que les
Champs-Élysées alors je sais pas ce que
ça donne sur les images que vous avez
vous mais nous vu d'ici en tout cas on
voit vraiment une foule assez compacte
et vraiment et bien énormément de
téléphones portables qui sont de sortie
pour pour prendre des photos et
immortaliser ce ce moment la
particularité également pour pour le
pilote de ce véhicule c'est que les
Champs-Élysées évidemment et bien ils
sont en pente douce et donc voilà c'est
c'est quelque chose à prendre en compte
pour pour le pilote de ce véhicule vous
le savez je vous l'ai dit ce sont et
bien bien évidemment entraînés préparer
à ce défilé depuis de nombreux jours
depuis la base aérienne de Brétigny mais
c'est vrai que si jamais exactement
pareil que lorsque l'on est dans dans
les conditions du réel ce défiler en
tout cas qui qui a démarré vous le voyez
ça y est nous sommes véritablement sur
les Champs-Élysées en train de de
défiler et nous devrions arriver et bien
au niveau de la de la tribune
présidentielle d'ici quelques minutes
et ben justement on va suivre ça alors
que effectivement on a vu que le début
du défilé motorisé qui continue ce
moment donc nous voyons la onzième
brigade parachutiste l'état-major de la
11e Brigade parachutiste qui appartient
à la troisième division du général
kadapo qui défile sur les fardiers c'est
fardier ce sont des tous nouveaux
véhicules là qui sont en train d'arriver
dans les forces et on l'a vu dans les
images précédentes il y avait à la fois
des overlands qui sont des véhicules
aérolargables d'anciennes génération qui
ont plus de 30 ans et seront remplacés
par les fardiers donc là nous voyons des
véhicules blindés légers ils sont des
véhicules plutôt de commandement avec le
premier régiment de hussard
parachutistes donc on est toujours avec
la onzième brigade parachutiste et les
grizzly que j'ai évoquais tout à l'heure
en couleur sable qui sont de nouveaux
véhicules que viennent percevoir ce
régiment des véhicules d'avant-garde
aéroportés avec une forte mobilité une
forte puissance de feu et derrière les i
mx-10 RC qui sont alors là on est encore
dans l'infanterie ou c'est déjà là on
était sur la partie cavalerie donc les
hussards c'est un régiment de cavalerie
légère et donc les IMX disrc fait partie
des des chars légers que nous avons cédé
à l'Ukraine
et donc là nous passons sur le troisième
RPIMa troisième régiment parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine voilà qui est
basé à Carcassonne et qui défile sur
donc le dernier le dernier né de la
famille scorpion donc le serval
qu'est-ce que permet ces véhicules ce
sont des véhicules de transport sont des
véhicules de combat aussi alors c'est
tous les véhicules que nous avons sont
des véhicules de combat et donc ceci en
particulier ils sont destinés aux
véhicules au pardon au combat aux zones
de contact et au brigades plutôt légères
donc plutôt l'infanterie que ça soit les
parachutistes ou la brigade alpine de
montagne et on les retrouvera aussi ce
type de véhicule là pour d'autres
fonctions dans l'appui ou la logistique
et une chose qu'on comprend pas quand on
est quand on est néophyte ou en tous les
cas quand on appartient pas à corps
militaire c'est on parle encore
d'infanterie cavalerie mais est-ce que
ça a encore du sens on voit plus de très
peu de de combat au corps à corps ou
très peu de combat à pied
je pense que l'Ukraine l'Ukraine nous
dit l'inverse bon déjà pour l'avoir vécu
personnellement
en Afghanistan ou sur d'autres lieux il
existe toujours des combats très
rapprochés et donc
l'infanterie qu'on dit l'arme des 300
mètres reste encore vraiment d'actualité
la cavalerie aujourd'hui l'Ukraine nous
l'a montré aussi le la nécessité d'avoir
des blindés la nécessité d'avoir des
chars et Charlots avec une puissance de
feu importante on voit d'ailleurs ici
les jaguars qui sont avec le premier
régent Régiment étranger de cavalerie le
Royal étranger qui défile c'est
également un de nos fleurons avec à la
fois un canon de 40 mm à la fois des
missiles moyennes portées qui pourront
tirer au-delà de la vue directe
c'est-à-dire qu'on pourra tirer sur une
cible qu'on observe par exemple par
drone ou par un autre moyen
vous voyez là aussi c'est le nouveau
cloud camouflage pardon que l'armée
terre va avoir et qui pourra être
modifié selon l'état d'engagement donc
la base initiale sur ces véhicules sera
le brin terre de France tel qu'on peut
le voir et ensuite on pourra adapter le
camouflage en fonction de la zone dans
laquelle on sera engagé là on revient
sur de l'infanterie c'est ça alors
l'infanterie ici avec les Griffons donc
il s'agit du 21e régiment d'infanterie
de marine qui est basé à Fréjus et donc
ce véhicule là est nouveau véhicule si
ça fait partie de ce qu'on appelle le
programme scorpion de l'armée de terre
exactement de renouvellement des
équipements de l'armée de terre
exactement donc ce véhicule est arrivé
lui déjà depuis quelques années il a été
mis d'abord à la sixième brigade légère
blindée qui va être la brigade dites
scorpionisée et qui va justement
travailler sur le ces échanges entre les
différents armes la connectivité pour
cumuler les effets sur le champ de
bataille
question justement un officier en charge
les questions capacitaires celui que
vous êtes
Charles nous dit les Ukrainiens disent
que nos chars léger ne supportent pas
les éclats d'obus c'est vrai c'est faux
alors c'est faux les chars légers que
nous avons ils ont une protection qui
est qui est adaptée à l'emploi pour
lesquels on est destiné les amx-10rc
sont des chars de reconnaissance donc
ils sont à employer nous les employons
en tout cas tels après j'ai pas de j'ai
pas moi de retour sur la façon dont ils
ont été employés en Ukraine
si elle m'ont Rima disait cette
cette internaute on peut dire que si on
prend les jargons des traditions
militaires c'est un fanat Marceau
c'est cela et en ce moment nous voyons
donc les vbc-i le véhicule blindé de
combat de l'infanterie autre matériel
qui a été renouvelé également voilà avec
un canon de 25 mm donc il y a de forts
effets sur sur l'adversaire
alors on a vu il y a un bataillon qui
est le bataillon de chasseurs à pied
mais
mais encore une fois pardon j'y reviens
ils étaient quand même toujours
à bord de véhicules longtemps cesser
en cultive dans l'infanterie on cultive
plusieurs façons de combattre pour les
bataillants de chasseurs à pieds qui
sont dans ce type de véhicule là on est
sur du combat mécanisé donc l'infanterie
légère c'est du combat motorisé voilà le
combat mécanisé c'est la différence
entre le mécanisé le motorisé et donc
c'est dans la vraiment dans la façon de
combattre on est à la frontière entre le
l'infanterie et la cavalerie donc on va
aller avec ce type de véhicule là
débarquer le fantassin au plus près de
la zone des contacts alors que dans
l'infanterie légère on va autoriser donc
motoriser voilà on va débarquer donc le
fantassin un peu en amont pour qu'il
puisse s'infiltrer et à attaquer
l'adversaire de façon peut-être un peu
plus discrète ou sur des endroits qui
les attendraient moins donc le on est
vraiment sur une approche un peu
différente là on est vraiment dans le
choc on va au contact fortement avec la
l'infanterie mécanisée
et donc là on va repasser au char cette
fois-ci donc le char le char Leclerc le
traditionnel voilà un de nos Florent
également qui qui aussi est en train
d'être rénové notamment sur les
différents optiques l'intégration aussi
future dans la bulle scorpion dont je
parlais tout à l'heure pour combiner les
les effets et donc ce char
est actuellement mis à l'honneur il est
dans le 500 1ième régiment de chars de
combat qui était en train de défiler qui
appartient donc à la deuxième brigade
blindée et on sait aussi une manière de
commémorer la libération de Paris
puisque comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous célébrons les quatre le
80ème anniversaire de la médaille de la
Résistance donc c'est également un clin
d'œil sur la libération de Paris et de
Strasbourg
et donc maintenant ce sont les
artilleurs avec les fameux canon César
voilà donc nous avons certainement votre
journaliste dans l'un de
ces véhicules voilà le bon le canon
César
Timothée est là est-ce que
avant on a plus l'image mais on a
peut-être le son de Timothée si nous
entend
mais effectivement il va nous raconter
en tout cas dans un instant
il en a parlé assez longuement très
efficace parce que très mobiles donc il
permet de tirer puis de partir et
d'éviter donc les tirs de
contre-batterie on a vu aussi passer
donc les drones le système de mini drone
de reconnaissance donc ces drone là donc
sont très importants pour également pour
la bulle aéro terrestre dont je parlais
tout à l'heure avec les hélicoptères
nous apporter du renseignement et de la
visibilité sur ce qui se passe là on a
vu des chats un peu particulier enfin
des véhicules un peu particulier avec
des pelleteuses ce sont des engins du
génie voilà qui ont pour vocation de
déblayer l'itinéraire par lequel on
passerait et ils ont aussi une capacité
à déminer voilà en lançant des
projectiles
alors d'autres d'autres giments et
notamment les régiments du train mais là
c'est pas des tracks qui défilent ce
sont des sourds des camions
qui sont c'est toujours le régiment de
transport et en particulier de transport
de matériel
c'est tout à fait ça donc là on a le
516ème régiment du Train donc sa
vocation est le transport
le déplacement tactique et opératif donc
c'est à dire déplacer des véhicules sur
de longues distances pour pouvoir
économiser on va dire leur mécanique
leur pièce etc on voit du vbc-i en ce
moment qui est transporté on a pu voir
du canon César des imx10rc qui qui comme
je disais tout à l'heure ont été des
véhicules qui qui ont été aussi cédés à
l'Ukraine pour participer à l'effort
derrière nous allons voir le septième
régiment du matériel qui pour lui sa
spécialité c'est tout ce qui est
logistique transport logistique donc
nous avons vu le transport des véhicules
là nous allons voir la partie logistique
et aujourd'hui on parlait dans le cadre
de la LPM la loi de programmation
militaire d'avoir de la profondeur
logistique de l'avoir de la cohérence
donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'on montre le
même on montre ce ces véhicules là on
montre ses capacités là qui sont
absolument nécessaires pour pouvoir
réapprovisionner nos troupes sur le
terrain pour pouvoir aussi on a un
dépanneur lourd sur la gauche du défilé
ce dépanneur voilà dépeindre tous les
véhicules sur le sur les terrains et les
théâtres d'opération
on devrait avoir du matériel un petit
peu plus lourd qui devrait être exposés
avec cette fois-ci des armes qui
appartiennent à l'armée de l'air
donc c'est ça c'est le le
vipère donc je suis en train de allez-y
celle qui était pas il y a un
contre-champ sur les sur la tribune
officielle donc
on peut tourner les pages
alors on a c'est ce sont des escadrons
solaires donc pour défendre donc le une
bulle terrestre une bulle pardon voilà
un espace terrestre qui serait à
protéger donc ça peut être des postes de
commandement ça peut être également une
zone comme le défilé du 14 juillet donc
c'est créer une bulle de défense solaire
et donc si un missile de croisière
intervenait c'est ces missiles là
pourraient les intercepter voilà et on
les voit actuellement à l'écran donc
c'est le système Mamba
moyenne porte et terrestre ça veut dire
on peut aller jusqu'à combien de
kilomètres
je pense qu'on est autour des des 70 100
km mais c'est ça reste à confirmer après
c'est un système qui est capable
d'opérer à 360 degrés voilà et qui comme
je disais à la fois intercepte des
missiles et aussi de une avion de chasse
enfin ou une aviation de chasse ennemi
l'interception d'une avion du navigation
de chasse et Nice ça veut dire que on
peut détruire des avions en vol
exactement
on a des systèmes courtes portés qui
sont tirés plus à la main on a des
systèmes ici moyenne portée
et alors là on quitte en tous les cas
les zones de combat
mais on reste dans les armées puisqu'on
a la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
Paris qui déjà vu tout à l'heure et une
nouvelle unité voilà la particularité
c'est que la
BSPP la Brigade des Sapeurs Pompiers de
Paris des fils systématiquement à la
fois à pied à la fois en véhicule
il rappelle que c'est le plus grand
corps de sapeurs-pompiers de d'Europe du
troisième dans le monde après New York
et après Tokyo
il n'y a pas simplement il y a pas
simplement les incendies et puis le
travail d'ailleurs classique des
pompiers mais il y a également la menace
terroriste qui qui englobé par la
brillade des sapeurs-pompiers de Paris
oui qui participe aussi avec la tout ce
qui est chimique la lutte contre les
menaces peut-être biologiques etc donc
ils ont effectivement ils prennent part
à tout ça donc c'est leur particularité
c'est un statut militaire comme les
marins de pompiers de Marseille
et donc ils sont engagés en permanence
au profit des parisiens avec un
engagement une intervention toutes les
toutes les 5 minutes de mémoire
et on va retrouver la garde républicaine
avec le premier avec le régiment de
cavalerie de la Garde Républicaine
on a eu un régiment d'infanterie
a pour mission principale de protéger
nos institutions on se pose à cheval en
permanence avec
aussi de façon saisonnière et il
participe à la protection de certains
sites et avec les unités de la
gendarmerie d'appartementale pour
l'anecdote aussi on a un peloton de
surveillance et d'intervention qui est
en Nouvelle-Calédonie en permanence que
j'ai pu rencontrer lorsque j'y étais
il y a deux ans
ces cavaliers donc on le disait sont
employés sur le contrôle de zone et la
recherche de personnes
font 15000 patrouille par an
[Musique]
donc vous pouvez voir l'ensemble de ces
véhicules sur les opérations de relation
publique
vous pourrez voir la notamment l'armée
de terre place de la Nation qui vous
présentera plusieurs des véhicules qui
ont défilé aujourd'hui et il y aura un
volet important sur l'innovation aussi
aux Invalides de 18h à 18h ou donc vous
pourrez voir l'ensemble des innovations
en cours l'innovation c'est une part
importante aujourd'hui dans le dans la
défense pour nous nous pousser vers
l'avant et faire face aux enjeux de
demain donc il y aura un investissement
important 10 milliards dans cette loi de
programmation militaire au profit de
l'innovation
et donc là avant la clôture du défilé
donc le régiment de cavalerie de la
Garde républicaine
succès toujours assuré
exactement qui ils ouvrent et ils
clôture ce défilé sur les Champs-Élysées
alors longtemps on va regarder ça comme
des régiments d'apparat mais aujourd'hui
en tous les cas c'est un article qui a
retrouvé sur le site du Figaro on
explique les bienfaits
de la de la police montée là en
l'occurrence la gendarmerie mais pour le
maintien de l'ordre donc c'est un
article
publié la semaine dernière et notamment
dans un certain nombre de communes de
police municipale qui ont recours
et bien à ce dispositif très très ancien
il y a quand même un effet dissuasif
[Musique]
d'un personnel des forces de l'ordre qui
qui est à cheval bon ça ça conforte
l'autorité
de ces forces de l'ordre
on les voyait il portait tous le bleu et
de France une nouvelle fois en mémoire
pour pour les blesser
il y avait une question justement je
voulais vous poser puisque vous allez
travailler sur cette question là on en a
on en a parlé tout à l'heure en quoi
consistait le programme Scorpion
alors le programme scorpion
initialement ça a été la modernisation
donc de des véhicules d'anciennes
génération beaucoup de véhicules de
l'armée de terre avaient entre 30 et 40
ans et face aux enjeux qui est au
nouveau combat qui auquel nous devions
faire face il était nécessaire donc de
se réadapter donc aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans une deuxième étape du combat
scorpion la le combat scorpion c'est le
combat collaboratif c'est ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est à dire
qu'on puisse avoir tous les véhicules
qui communiquent ensemble et qui ont une
capacité presque automatique
de réagir et de communiquer c'est-à-dire
que on pourrait avoir sur le même champ
de bataille à plusieurs dizaines de
kilomètres un véhicule qui observe ou un
drone qui observe un ennemi et ça serait
un autre véhicule qui est un petit peu
plus loin qui serait sur les arrières
etc qui viendraient
donc réagir et traiter détruire cette
ennemi donc on est vraiment sur une
communication
utiliser toutes les informations qu'on
peut échanger par l'informatique
d'aujourd'hui en faire une analyse et
créer une réaction rapide le but c'est
vraiment d'accélérer le combat et de de
de dépasser l'adversaire
d'animation finale les 80 ans de la
médaille de la Résistance qui sont à
l'honneur on a une pensée également pour
le général Baptiste vous êtes sur le
site du Figaro vous avez bien raison d'y
être sur le site ou sur Youtube avec les
meilleurs commentaires et les meilleurs
analyses avec les reporters également
sur place qu'on va retrouver
la médaille de la Résistance
c'est une décoration qui n'a pas attendu
la fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
pour être créé puisque
c'est sinon en fait pas les 80 ans
aujourd'hui il me direz-vous mais c'est
donc pendant le conflit que cette
distinction a été créée c'est ça donc
elle a été créée pendant le conflit pour
justement reconnaître ceux qui s'était
déjà engagé et poussé peut-être d'autres
à continuer de s'engager en montrant la
reconnaissance de la nation et de la
France libre à ce moment-là avec
également donc le Conseil National de la
Résistance qui a été créé à la même
époque et on le verra aussi dans le
tableau c'est une manière aussi de
commémorer la disparition de Jean Moulin
sur la même période
[Musique]
dans le premier annulation avec
la marche de la Libération
écrite par Jules composé par Jules
sémeler Collery et puis on aura ensuite
le fameux chant des partisans
créé par Joseph Kessel et Maurice Druon
qui était le même
membre des Forces françaises libres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici chacun se quitte ce qui est mort il
passe
[Musique]
a mis son monde à ta place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il pleurait
la liberté
voilà et l'animation va continuer avant
de nous quitter avant de vous quitter
mais
quenelles les Muller quel est le l'image
que vous a le plus frappé depuis le
début de ce défilé
je crois qu'en fait il y en a plusieurs
difficile de dire que cette image là qui
se passe en ce moment qui est quand même
chargé d'émotion
ne peut pas être une image marquante
moi ce que je retiendrai de ce défiler
c'est une modernité modernité de l'armée
française de ses équipements mais
surtout on a mis à l'honneur la jeunesse
on le voit encore à l'écran on a mis
honneur à l'honneur la réserve on a mis
à l'honneur nos armées d'actives et nos
partenaires donc je trouve que ça a été
tout ça une belle image de ce que peut
représenter nos forces morales merci
beaucoup colonel
lieutenant-colonel bientôt colonel on
vous le souhaite Vincent les Muller pour
pour ce commentaire
on va continuer de suivre en DIRECT les
derniers instants de ce défiler
notamment la lecture d'une lettre de
Jean Moulin adressée à sa famille
lecture faite par la commissaire des
armées Alix menuet lauréate du prix
Clémenceau 2022 qui est le prix de
l'éloquence du ministère des armées avec
comme accompagnement l'interlude de
Philippe sparkles en présence de jeunes
du service national universel du service
cycle civique et des candés de la
gendarmerie nationale notamment et bien
sûr des préparations militaires terre et
Marilyn et des escadrilles air jeune r
jeunesse
les pauvres départements et mutilés et
feignant de toutes parts rien n'a
épargné la population civile
quand vous recevrez cette lettre
j'aurai sans doute rempli une dernier
devoir
sur ordre du gouvernement j'aurais reçu
les Allemands au chef-lieu de mon
département et je serai prisonnier
je suis sûre que notre victoire
prochaine grâce à un sursaut
d'indignation du monde et à l'héroïsme
de nos soldats viendra le délivré
je ne savais pas que c'était si simple
de faire ce devoir quand on est en
danger
si par hasard je ne revenais pas de
cette aventure je voudrais que vous
réalisiez un souhait que je formule de
mon jeune
[Musique]
voilà donc la lecture de la lettre de
Jean Moulin fait on demandait sur
Youtube par qui et bien par Alix menuet
qui est commissaire des armées et qui
avait remporté le Prix Clémenceau 2022
qui est le prix d'éloquence du ministère
des armées avec à ses côtés une une
cinquantaine de jeunes colonel Yann
mandreau qui eux-mêmes
portaient un certain nombre de de
coussins qui montrent l'engagement
également de la France sur sur un
certain nombre de
de terrain et de territoire
et c'est le passé la Marseillaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
séquence finale séquence traditionnelle
de ces fins de 14 juillet
qu'on vient d'entendre alors avec cette
année colonel Yann mandrew des
spécificités avec la jeunesse qui était
mise à l'honneur et également l'esprit
de résistance oui tout à fait
les forces morales donc le pont entre
cette esprit de résistance aussi qui
prend tout un sens particulier cette
année avec le DCI il y a une dizaine de
jours et les hommages qui ont été rendus
vendredi dernier de à Léon Gauthier le
dernier des premiers l'un des 177
jours et à qui on a rendu l'hommage et
ensuite cette jeunesse représentée par
la jeunesse des lycées français
africains et ces jeunes présents
aujourd'hui pour faire le pont entre le
passé et le futur le gouverneur
militaire de Paris qui général
de corps d'armée Christophe Abad qui
salut
Emmanuel Macron et le Premier ministre
indien maudit qui était donc l'invité
d'honneur de ce de ce défilé
avec
des médaillés de la Résistance
effectivement
l'une des grandes figures de cette
alors de cette résistance plus encore de
débarquement qui était Leon Gauthier qui
était le dernier membre des commandos
qui faire qui nous a qui nous a quitté
il y a maintenant à la fin du mois de
juin et qui
[Musique]
reçu également les honneurs
nationaux sur la plage de Ouistreham il
avait il avait débarqué
sur sa fin de vie les 80 ans de la
médaille de la Résistance aux en parliez
tout à l'heure 65000 personnes ont reçu
cette médaille de 25000 à titre costumes
la deuxième des médailles et la dernière
qui a été créée à l'occasion de la
deuxième guerre mondiale on a vu des
coussins qui étaient portés tout à
l'heure par les membres de la réserve
opérationnelle qui symbolisait également
les les villes qui ont été décorées
parce que il y a pas simplement des
personnes il y a également des unités en
fait 55 unités et collectivités qui ont
été décorées de cette médaille de la
Résistance qui était donc porté par des
des réservistes et aussi des jeunes des
jeunes français des préparations
militaires ou du service national
universel qui porte ses coussins pour
représenter ces 55 collectivités ou
unités normalement une croix de Lorraine
doit être formé ou et former mais là à
ce niveau là on le voit pas on la voyait
tout à l'heure oui tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est le symbole et une croix de
Lorraine qu'on voyait d'ailleurs sur la
porte du canon César à l'intérieur
duquel se trouvait Timothée
voilà la Croix-Rouge et l'Ordre de Malte
également qui sont mises à l'honneur
et le drapeau de la résistance qui est
en première ligne
son fameux ces fameux coussins donc où
sont qui représentent donc les unités et
les collectivités qui avaient été
distinguées par cette médaille de la
Résistance
[Musique]
on va retrouver pendant ce temps Damien
Canivez qui est sur les Champs-Elysées
Damien vous avez suivi le défi vous êtes
avec des personnes qui étaient venues
pour le suivre
absolument nous avons suivi le défilé en
entier nous sommes là actuellement
avenue Gabriel qui est une avenue qui se
trouve en parallèle de l'avenue des
Champs-Élysées je suis effectivement
avec Joe qui a suivi le défilé lui aussi
qui s'est levé de bon matin pour y
assister bonjour alors la question que
j'avais envie de me poser premièrement
est-ce que vous avez aimé déjà ce défi
énormément oui
le passage des Leclerc ça faisait
longtemps qu'on les avait pas vu et
s'ils sont toujours aussi
impressionnants et voilà j'ai beaucoup
aimé aussi les chiens qui les maîtres
chiens et les pompiers évidemment
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui vous a
étonné le plus dans dans les dans les
chars Leclerc
on les voit pas souvent en fait
les civils ont l'habitude de les voir en
dans des reportages ou dans des photos
mais pas souvent en vrai et là ils
étaient très proches et c'était très
impressionnant au niveau du bruit
notamment alors ce qui est aussi
impressionnant c'est votre cravate
cravate bleu blanc rouge vous êtes
habillé dans le cadre du 14 juillet aux
couleurs de la France
plus exactement je suis en fait partie
d'une association de porte de drapeau
national qui s'appelle les ACPG CATM
donc qui vient en aide notamment aux
anciens prisonniers de guerre et qui est
composé d'entre eux qui vient aussi aux
veuves etc et donc étant donné que je
suis pas en drapeau je suis je viens
plus d'image
ça a coupé
on retrouvera sa magie du direct on
retrouvera Damien vous le voyez en ce
moment sur ces images la le défilé prend
fin et les
délégations en tous les cas les les
représentants des des personnes qui ont
défilé ont été saluées et en particulier
des les armées indiennes ont été des
représentants de l'armée indienne ont
été salués par le Président de la
République et narenda maudit le Premier
ministre indien et il va faire une
déclaration conjointe et Madame les deux
hommes d'État doivent deux chefs d'État
doivent faire deux dirigeants plus
exactement c'est un chef d'État et après
le ministre doivent faire une
déclaration conjointe à
17h05
à l'issue du déjeuner qu'ils vont avoir
à l'Élysée est-ce que Emmanuel Macron va
aller sal les personnes autour des
tribunes c'est
une tradition
lors de ces depuis qu'il est arrivé
à l'Élysée
effectivement on le voit prendre congé
du Premier ministre indien c'est un peu
confus au niveau de l'image on va
revenir peut-être en plateau non là
l'image est plus claire on voit le chef
d'état-major des armées le général
burqar on va retrouver Timothée d'Hélène
si nous entend qui lui a défilé vécu ce
défilé à l'intérieur donc d'un des
canons César
Timothée et bien vous êtes en train de
prendre position là je vois pour la
nouvelle phase pour de cette journée qui
va être celle de l'exposition au public
et il me semble que vous êtes près de
l'Esplanade des Invalides
absolument avoir ça vous avez bien
reconnu le dôme des Invalides que l'on
voit là en haut de en haut de l'image
c'est ici que la suite des opérations
j'allais dire va se passer caler quelle
est la suite du programme maréchal des
logis ah pour moi c'est toute
l'après-midi aux Invalides à présenter
le César à la population française ça
c'est un moment important aussi c'est
l'occasion de de créer ce lien avec la
population oui correct c'est au moment
d'échanger de montrer ce qu'on a ce que
l'on sait faire peut-être trouver des
voies pour certaines personnes et vous
disiez juste à la fin de ce défiler
lorsque nous avons quitté les
Champs-Élysées que c'est l'occasion
aussi de c'est le moment aussi ce 14
juillet se défiler où on se rencontre du
lien qu'il y a avec la population et
finalement de de la popularité de
l'armée auprès de auprès des Français
impressionné par le nombre de personnes
qui avaient sur les sur les côtés tout
le long de la descente c'est on se
croirait la Coupe du Monde 98 et il y a
certaines personnes également qui vous
ont qui vous ont saluer qui vous
souhaitez une une bonne journée
j'imagine que c'est des c'est des choses
qui font qui font chaud au cœur aussi
tout simplement ça fait plaisir c'est un
peu pourquoi on s'engage grâce à des
réactions comme ça
voilà on va on va se tourner peut-être
également vers le pilote si les
disponible comment vous avez vécu ce
défilé et cette et notamment ces
instants où vous êtes retrouvés face au
chef de l'État et au chef d'état-major
des armées bah c'était merveilleux et
surtout une chance pour toutes les
personnes qui étaient présentes et voilà
c'est un moment on imagine dont vous
vous souviendrez toute votre vie oui
bien sûr voilà Vincent pour pour cette
première réaction à la fin de ce défiler
vous le voyez nous sommes en train de
nous diriger vers vers l'Esplan vers
l'esplanade des Invalides avec toujours
beaucoup de monde dehors et qui qui
regardent ces camions militaires passés
ces camions il faut dire très imposant
et qui et qui viennent saluer également
les les militaires voilà dans une dans
une très très bonne ambiance alors que
le soleil parisien en plus vient égayer
encore plus cette journée merci
coût Timothée vous restez avec nous on
va vous dire dans quelques instants vous
allez nous raconter comment vous avez
vécu ce défilé images instant donc
effectivement comme
il est de couture depuis qu'il est à
l'Élysée Emmanuel Macron est allé à la
rencontre des personnes qui sont venues
elles dans les tribunes officielles
autour dans les tribunes qui étaient
autour de la tribune officielle plus
exactement on va suivre ce on va suivre
cette séquence on va essayer de
retrouver Damien Canivez
qui était une pas très loin d'ailleurs
de là où se trouve le président de la
République et avoir les réactions des
personnes qui ont suivi ce défilé c'est
assez intéressant de ce qu'on entendait
tout à l'heure
justement que le mandro le fait de voir
les passer les chars Leclerc finalement
les Français ils aiment bien enfin
certains ceux qui viennent aiment bien
voir ces ces nouveaux
c'est nouveau matériel vous militaire je
sais pas si vous avez eu l'occasion
d'avoir cette expérience d'être
justement au contact des personnes qui
viennent voir c'est ces personnages
comment vous le vivez ça alors
effectivement c'est quelque chose qu'on
aime bien faire mettre en avant les
matériels que l'on a et l'expliquer
l'expliquer au à la population qui vient
nous rencontrer il y aura plusieurs
occasions cet après-midi on a parlé aux
invalides mais aussi dans différents
endroits de la capitale à Nation pour
l'armée de terre l'hôtel de ville pour
la marine et André Citroën pour l'armée
de l'arrêt de l'espace justement pour
montrer nos nouveaux matériels et dont
une partie seront remplacement les
anciens en cours de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire donc j'encourage
tous les parisiens ceux qui sont
présents en région parisienne à venir
cet après-midi à la rencontre de leur
armée le message est passé j'ai admiré
nous dit Garance la Légion ceux qui sont
tous faire et qui ne se séparent jamais
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'interpré tation du
Chant des Partisans alors ce qui est
vrai c'est que on l'entendait moins la
lecture de la lettre de Jean Moulin
c'est ce que en tous les cas des
reproches qui étaient faits sur sur
Youtube par
Alix menuet qui est le commissaire des
armées s'était recouvert par par la
musique de de l'interlude de Philippe
Spark
la grandeur de militaire de la grandeur
militaire de notre pays est désormais
loin derrière nous nous dit cette
internaute
Garance son corps c'est nous qui payons
l'armement de l'Ukraine avec la dette
ferramineuse que nous avons alors
l'armement de l'Ukraine pour l'instant
on l'a vu c'est son quai ce sont des des
scalpes qui sont données ce qu'on a
appris notamment d'ailleurs au cours de
cette de ce défilé c'est que de
l'armement que l'on donne à l'Ukraine il
y a également beaucoup d'armements qui
en fin de vie également alors oui c'est
ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure sur
sur les chars de reconnaissance on a le
l'ensemble de la gamme scorpion qui va
être mise en place ou continuer d'être
mise en place au cours de la prochaine
loi de programmation militaire 2300
blindés on en a vu certains défilés
aujourd'hui 109 canon César de nouvelles
générations qui viennent donc remplacer
les anciens matériels et donc qui les
remplace pour mettre finir en place la
modernisation de l'armée de terre
vous pour réaction vous nous dites ce
qui vous a le plus marqué pendant
pendant ce défiler alors que l'on voit
Emmanuel Macron saluait les familles les
blessés sont également chaque année à
l'honneur on le disait tout à l'heure et
également il y a eu un
un hommage enfin tous les cas une pensée
non pas pour un blessé mais pour un mort
qui était le
sapeur-pompier qui devait défiler et qui
est mort à Saint-Denis lors d'une
opération contre un incendie de véhicule
dans un appartement
une dizaine de jours
et qui aurait dû défiler tout à l'heure
à pied au sein de la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de Paris aucun hommage
particulier évidemment aujourd'hui lui
est rendu donc effectivement le chef de
l'État qui comme chaque année fait fait
le tour et donc salut les salut la foule
qui est présente dont les blessés
le chef de l'État mais
fait un effort pour aller saluer
l'ensemble des blessés présents dans les
tribunes un internaute nous demande la
crise de recrutement dans l'armée
française on en parle est-ce qu'il y a
une crise de recrutement aujourd'hui
alors
actuellement on a une baisse
de recrutement
au sein au sein des armées une baisse
une baisse en ce moment effectivement
conséquence de la crise covid le fait
que nos les jeunes n'ont pas pu
rencontrer les recruteurs c'est un
processus généralement long on rencontre
quelqu'un on y réfléchit et un deux ans
après on s'engage voilà il faut enfin je
ne peux qu'encourager les jeunes qui se
posent des questions qui qui cherchent
leur voix qui cherchent un métier qui
est qui a du sens à venir cet après-midi
ou simplement pousser un jour la porte
d'un surface juste discuter prendre un
premier contact pour pour se poser les
questions savoir si si à terme ça
pourrait les intéresser de s'engager les
dans les armées sachant qu'il y a
véritablement de la place pour tout le
monde et tous ceux qui pourraient être
potentiellement intéressés on va essayer
de retrouver Timothée délai
[Musique]
qui est maintenant place des Invalides
on n'a pas son image donc dès qu'on l'a
on essaiera de le retrouver peut-être
une question avant que on retrouve
éventuellement Timothée et Damien sur
sur le terrain
l'image qui nous a le plus frappé
aujourd'hui ce que vous retiendrez en
tous les cas de ce défiler alors
entre la jeunesse et nos anciens la
jeunesse moi ce qui m'a le plus marqué
c'est les lycées africains qui qui
défilaient parce que c'est à la fois la
jeunesse et notre notre partenariat avec
avec nos avec nos amis avec nos amis des
pays africains qui étaient présents
aujourd'hui et le pont avec le tableau
final la médaille de la Résistance et
nos et nos anciens c'est véritablement
moi ça qui m'a marqué cette cette année
sur sur ce défilé le pont entre nos
anciens et nos jeunes qui sont appelés à
terme à leur succéder
Emmanuel Macron encore à la rencontre
des personnes présentes
le président de la République qui n'ont
que
multiplie les images mais pas les
déclarations il a renoncé à l'interview
du 14 juillet il devra quand même faire
une déclaration il en a fait une hier
soir à l'Hôtel de Brienne devant les
armées où il a annoncé que le prochain
défilé n'aurait pas lieu sur les
Champs-Élysées mais entre Vincennes et
la place de la Nation avec flamme
olympique ça sera pour l'édition du 14
juillet 2024 et le président de la
République doit s'exprimer aujourd'hui
de nouveau à 17h05 avec au côté du
Premier ministre indien
narenda modéi le Premier ministre indien
qui a assisté et qui est lui qui a
assisté à se défiler et qui a quitté les
lieux on va essayer de retrouver une
dernière fois Timothée délaime
place des Invalides
Timothée vous avez débarqué normalement
à vous êtes en train en plein en plein
débarquement alors on va vous laisser
peut-être
débarquer de votre
canon César mais comme ça ça
vous entends mais c'est vrai que ça nous
permet de le voir de l'intérieur
justement et de faire la de continuer la
visite qui était commencée tout à
l'heure avec le maréchal des logis et
donc de voir et bien dans quel véhicule
les armées font la guerre
250 véhicules étaient sur la parade de
exactement voilà vous voyez l'intérieur
de ce de ce canon César en fait on est
en train de débarquer sur cette
esplanade des Invalides parce que et
bien toute l'après-midi il va y avoir un
certain nombre d'animations pour faire
découvrir aux gens et bien ce type de ce
type d'engin voilà vous voyez
l'intérieur avec le pilote tout à
l'heure qui nous a conduit qui nous a
conduit lors de ce défilé et puis nous
sommes en train tout simplement de
débarquer voilà vous voyez cette image
en direct voilà c'est les conditions du
direct et vous voyez ici un certain
nombre d'animations avec d'autres
d'engins également devant nous vous
reconnaissez cette esplanade des
Invalides sur laquelle je viens tout
juste d'arriver avec un speaker là qui
est en train et bien de s'adresser à la
foule parce que voilà beaucoup
d'animations vont être mises en place
cet après-midi vous voyez le maréchal
des logis Richard qui qui a eu la
gentillesse de nous donner ses
explications à plusieurs reprises tout à
l'heure qui est en train en gare de
donner ses instructions pilote pour
garer définitivement ce ce canon César
ce fameux canon César et puis sous
l'oeil évidemment de de toutes ces
personnes qui sont là et qui vont et
bien chercher à peut-être comprendre
aussi comment comment tout cela
fonctionne grâce aux explications de de
ces militaires qui ont donc qui seront
donc en tout cas disponibles tout au
long de l'après-midi pour et bien
rencontrer rencontrer les les Français
qui souhaitent comprendre un petit peu
mieux comment comment fonctionne ce type
d'engin
Timothée ce sera ma dernière question
mais comment vous avez passé ce défilé
comment vous avez vécu ce défilé à
l'intérieur du du scanon on a
l'impression que c'est beaucoup
d'attentes mais finalement c'est assez
rapide
alors effectivement Timothée a pas dû
m'entendre parce que on avait dû avoir
un problème de connexion donc je repose
ma question à Timothée vous avez passé
ce comment vous avez vécu ce défilé on a
l'impression que c'est beaucoup
d'attentes mais finalement pour pour un
passage qui est assez réduit assez
rapide
oui Vincent c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu beaucoup d'attentes et
encore il y en a eu davantage pour ces
pour ces militaires parce que leur
premier briefing comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure a eu lieu à trois heures
et quart du matin du côté de du côté de
la base aérienne de Brétigny nous sommes
retrouvés à 6h45 aux abords de l'Arc de
Triomphe pour tout vous dire et c'est
vrai qu'ensuite il y a beaucoup
d'attentes mais en même temps c'est une
attente positive j'allais dire parce
qu'on sait que qu'on va passer un bon
moment on sait que que c'est un jour de
fête nationale la descente à proprement
parler dure 13 minutes c'est sur ces
Champs-Élysées qui font qui font à peu
près quasiment 2 km un petit peu moins
donc voilà c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
ça passe vite ça passe vite mais en même
temps on passe un bon moment vous le
voyez d'ailleurs là les les Français qui
sont encore en train de prendre des
photos de venir saluer les de venir
saluer les militaires c'est vrai que ça
passe vite un élément quand même je le
lis parce que c'est vrai que c'était
c'était assez inconvénient il faisait
chaud très très chaud dans ce dans ce
qu'anon César au moment où nous avons où
nous avons défilé parce que évidemment
les les vitres étaient toutes fermées et
donc c'est vrai que c'est un véritable
four comme comme lisait le pilote tout à
l'heure mais ça c'est aussi parce que
nous n'avons tout simplement pas activé
la climatisation parce qu'elle fait
beaucoup de bruit et qu'on aurait eu du
mal à m'entendre voilà mais en temps
normal rassurez-vous pour nos pour nos
militaires ils disposent d'une clim
d'une climatisation lorsqu'ils sont
lorsqu'ils sont sur déployés sur les
théâtres d'opérations donc voilà je vous
confirme c'est vrai que c'est pas si
vite mais en même temps c'est un bon
moment c'est un bon souvenir un bon
souvenir que je garde en tête mais
également que ces militaires garderont
en tête ils garderont en tête
probablement toute leur vie en tout cas
c'est ce qui me disait tout à l'heure
merci beaucoup Timothée on a vu des
personnalités de l'armée de l'air mais
je ne sais pas lesquels étaient
exactement oui j'ai pas fait attention
je vais tout à l'heure le général mando
le chef d'état-major particulier et là
je oui j'ai du mal à distinguer parmi le
la foulard on va vous laisser sur ces
sur ces dernières images un grand merci
colonel
mondreau de nous avoir de nous avoir
accompagné avec le lieutenant-colonel
Vincent les Muller pour ce cette
nouvelle édition du du défilé du 14
juillet la prochaine et bien elle ne
sera pas là elle sera sur les sur la
place de la Nation en tout cas entre
Vincennes et la place de la Nation comme
ça c'était fait dans les années 70 à
grand merci de nous avoir suivis merci
beaucoup vous avez été nombreux à
commenter à nous partager vos réactions
vos commentaires à la fois sur le site
pardon sur youtube il y a eu un moment
un bug sur le chat on n'a pas pu avoir
recevoir toutes les images toutes les
toutes les suivre toutes les réactions
et c'est pour ça qu'il n'y a pas répondu
mais à culpa maintenant pour les images
c'était donc assuré par l'AFP mais merci
beaucoup d'avoir été présent et d'avoir
apporté tous ces éclairages tous ces
commentaires bon courage pour les prises
de pour la suite des opérations on
espère pour les prises de commandement
également on vous le souhaite merci pour
tous les cas
si vous commandez aussi bien que vous
commentez et bien on aura je
on aimerait bien être les troupes sous
vos sous votre direction sur vos
commandements merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivis un grand merci également à
tous ceux qui ont permis cette édition
spéciale dans cette émission spéciale ce
live spécial dans les locaux du Figaro
dans les nouveaux du Figaro vous en
rendez pas compte mais ils sont tout
neufs on n'a pas eu tellement le temps
des expérimenter et donc c'était une
logistique de
nos équipes techniques merci à donc
Jean-Pierre Van Elder directeur
technique des nouveaux médias du Figaro
Damien Perpignan avec lui Sylvain
châtelain riadbekir red de Marie degrés
du loup à la coordination bien
évidemment on n'oublie pas Timothée
délai Julien Leclerc et Damien Canivez
sur le terrain Sandrine Desforges romain
Mallard Thibault Gauthier qui a préparé
toute l'opération depuis le début et
bien sûr j'avais oublié jeudi Sandrine
desforge mais c'est Elodie qui était
avec nous ce matin vous les voyez pas et
une mention spéciale une mention
spéciale à Marine landeau qui nous a
passé un ultime coup de main qui a été
la maîtresse de de
ce déménagement du Figaro rue de
Provence et qui a fini en apothéose ce
matin ici dans les studios du Figaro
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi vous
restez en direct vous restez avec nous
on vous laisse sur ces images et vous
n'oubliez pas prochain live 17h 17h05
avec Emmanuel Macron et ce soir libre à
vous avec Guillaume demanjou ce sera à
20h à très vite sur le Figaro
oui j'ai vu oui
de poule qui était censé être là le fil
à vos clients
alors
il va se
servir déjà ils sont dans la foule
là ils ont le droit de le faire du
rapprocher
mais ça devrait être cool ça
devrait être
là c'est pas normal
ouais mais je vais lui dire après
ouais moi je reste là au cas où on ne
sait jamais
là-bas je suis passé
c'est la moindre des choses
je viens de voir
ça va ça va mieux
et la tension
j'ai entendu parler mais je la connais
pas
elle va bien
alors
ça va
j'ai voyagé avec
bon je vous laisse faire les courses et
puis je vous appelle quand je te dis
donc allez bonne journée et bonne fête
de l'indépendance
je crois que tu as
ah non il est là
une veste c'est au moins 10000 euros
c'était pensé tissus
il y a encore c'est plus que partie là
aussi la réforme
ça s'est déplacé vers le bas
qui parle avec Miss France
salut Olivier
à bientôt
ça va et toi